All right. What's up, y'all? As always,
welcome, welcome, welcome. Should be a
good stream tonight. Hopefully, it's
going to be in depth. Um,
might want to grab a notebook.
It's going to be uh information, maybe
overload, probably overload, but it
needs done. So, uh it's been a a long
time coming on this. So tonight we are
going to look at only about eight
minutes or so of a presentation that
Mark Finley gave not too long ago titled
Seven Reasons that Satan Hates the
Sabbath. Um for those that do not know,
Mark Finley is a bigname uh one of these
platformed SDA evangelists,
international evangelists that basically
has mastered the SDA script and is a
very good orator. um I guess according
to some people uh but one of the top
salesmen in the the program if you will.
He has a YouTube channel called Hope
Lives 365 which is where this video was
uploaded um a couple months ago I think
it was. But anyways, we're going to use
it more as a teaching tool than anything
else because Mark is not unique in what
he claims here. This is standard fair
SDA assertions and claims. So, we will
use him as the example to hopefully help
others by putting to bed some of the
standard myths that the SDA church has
been promoting from its inception. As
you will see,
um, we're going to show that Mark Finley
and the other SDA leaders that parrot
this stuff do not know what they are
critiquing.
They do not know what they criticize.
The standard claim is that Christians
have no basis for why they worship on
Sunday. No biblical basis. that were
deceived by Satan to do so because it's
Satan's Sabbath that we observe. Um, and
I'm going to show beyond a shadow of a
doubt the SDA church is full of it. They
have rewritten history and has uh really
well, yeah, I mean, from their inception
for far too long, they've relied on you
and I being too lazy to fact check them.
So, the question I have for the
classroom tonight is twofold.
Who is worshiping creation rather than
the creator? And who is being faithful
to all of the biblical text when it
comes to the subject of the Sabbath?
Okay.
Who is worshiping creation rather than
the creator? You'll see why I'm why I'm
asking that here. And who is being
faithful to all of the biblical text
when it comes to the subject of the
Sabbath because those are the central
charges that the Adventist church is
making about Christians as you will see
Mark Finley claim. And I understand not
everyone is going to agree with my
position, not just Seventh Day
Adventists. There's going to be other
people that disagree. That's completely
fine. But I would challenge you to hear
out what's being said tonight. The
Adventist church has relied too long on
a false dichotomy depiction on this
subject that you have the Adventist view
on one side and everyone who disagrees
is on this other side. And this is not
true. and they like it being this way
because their arguments only work on
people who fit into that other box that
they've assigned everyone else to. I
have been studying this topic for a long
time. I have been preparing for this
presentation for a long time as well.
And that's in relation to how much I
prep for the other presentations or live
streams that I do because it is going to
be a lot of information between
scripture and history. We are going to
be looking at a large scale amount of
sources. I will try and go at a
digestible pace and be as articulate as
I can, but I also don't want to be here
for five hours. So, we will start with
some historical information on the
subject followed by a bunch of scripture
capped off with um some more history
there at the end. What we're talking
about tonight is the chief reputation of
the SDA Old Creation Memorial Sabbath.
I'll say it again. What we're talking
about tonight is the chief reputation of
the SDA Old Creation Memorial Sabbath.
And if you're wondering why I'm wording
it that way, you'll see after a bit. But
we're going to get into the ancient
argument that the church has been using
against 7th Day Sabotarian uh the
seventh day sabotarian position from its
inception. They cannot refute this nor
deal with it. They rely on you using bad
arguments like saying the law was nailed
to the cross and nine out of ten
commandments are repeated in the New
Testament, etc. but they are not
equipped to deal with what we're going
to look at tonight. And if this clicks
in your mind, I can assure you, you will
have the theological bazooka that blows
their position out of orbit.
And as always, I will mention this
later. It's not because of me. I'm just
the one presenting the information. It's
the word of God, when rightly
understood, that is the anvil that can
wear out any hammer. Because we're going
to look at things for consistency. We're
going to look at all sorts of stuff
tonight. And all that stuff matters as
well.
The truth is not afraid of scrutiny,
folks, and should be open to
examination. So, what I'm going to share
with you tonight is not answering
Adventism's own private interpretation.
I say that very frequently, mainly to
say I stand on the shoulders of giants,
and I want to equip the body of Christ
to not fall prey to these silly SDA
myths and historical revisionism with
their gotchas and sort of cheap tricks,
as you're going to see. So, if that
sounds good,
let's get into it.
Class is in session. Here we go.
Ination
in the outer darkness of this world. I
picture a diabolical scene.
Some places in the far someplace in the
far reaches of space,
a rebel angel meets with his demonic
forces in a strategy session.
Now, the forces of evil and darkness are
eager to be successful in their devilish
scheme.
In my imagination, I see this committee
meeting, if you please, and the devil is
discussing with his evil angels how best
to undermine the authority of Christ.
Now, to do this, they determine in that
meeting to focus particularly
on the Sabbath. They'll attempt to
discredit, destroy, and demolish
God's symbol of creation, the Sabbath,
in any way possible. So, they begin to
discuss this and they, in my
imagination, I hear them debating and
they decide on at least five major
objectives. First, the devil is going to
lead millions of people to worship
the object of creation, the sun, rather
than the creator of creation. He
introduces in Egypt, for example, the
son god Emmanra and they worship the sun
god. He introduces in Babylon Belarduk,
the sun god. He issu he introduces in
Persia Mithra the sun god. He introduces
in Greece Helios and Apollo the sun
gods. He introduces in Rome soul the sun
god and millions accept sun worship
down through the centuries rather than
Sabbath worship.
Okay. So, right out of the gate,
Satan held a diabolical strategy session
to destroy the Sabbath. Did you notice
he kept crediting? So, he started at the
beginning. It was a little cut off
there. The very first words that he says
is in my imagination and then he
mentioned it again there. Did you notice
he kept crediting this to his
imagination? Mark, you are confusing
your imagination with uh the writings of
Ellen G. White. Either that or your
imagination has been influenced by Ellen
White because that's who you are
paraphrasing. So let's look at this now
folks. A diabolical session was held by
Satan
in outer space
where he was scheming how to completely
destroy the Sabbath. Coming from the
movement too that wants to fault us as
you'll see tonight and all the time.
They just believe the Bible. those other
people. No, they they don't have any
biblical basis for for Sunday.
So, where is he getting this from?
Let's take a peek. Let's read a couple
pages. All right.
Because spoiler alert again, Mark's
imagination is code word for Ellen White
says, and this is the foundation of his
entire talk. So, we're going to read a
bit here. I want to get this whole thing
because his whole talk tonight is
predicated upon his imagination here.
So, notice what she says.
Oh, I need to scroll up some, I think.
Uh, let's see. What page are we starting
on? Here we go.
She starts off, she says, "As the people
of God approach the perils of the last
days, Satan holds earnest consultation
with his angels as to the most
successful plan of overthrowing their
faith. He sees that the popular churches
are already lulled to sleep by his
deceptive power. By pleasing sophistry
and lying wonders, he can continue to
hold them under his control. Therefore,
he directs his angels to lay their
snares, especially for those who are
looking for the second advent of Christ
and endeavoring to keep all the
commandments of God. That's Adventist.
Wink wink wink. They're the ones that
are waiting for the return of Christ
because they're keeping all the
commandments of God. Says the great
deceiver, "We must watch those who are
calling the attention of the people to
the Sabbath of Jehovah. They will lead
many to see the claims of the law of God
in the same light which reveals the true
Sabbath reveals also the ministration of
Christ in the heavenly sanctuary and
shows that the last work for the people
in darkness till the work is ended or
sorry I skipped a line and shows that
the last work for man's salvation is now
going forward. Hold the minds of the
people in darkness till that work is
ended and we shall secure the world and
the church also. So Satan apparently
really cares about the investigative
judgment as well because that's what
he's referencing there. The Sabbath is
the great question which is to decide
the destiny of souls.
We must exalt the Sabbath of our
creating. Oh, so Satan created a
Sabbath. We've caused it to be accepted
by both worldlings and church members.
Now the church must be led to unite with
the world in its support. We must work
by signs and wonders to blind their eyes
to the truth and lead them to lay aside
reason and the fear of God and follow
custom and tradition.
You seeing where this is going?
I will influence popular ministers to
turn the attention of their hearers from
the commandments of God. That which the
scriptures declare to be a perfect law
of liberty shall be represented as a
yoke of bondage. The people accept their
ministers explanations of scripture and
do not investigate for themselves.
Therefore, by working through the
ministers, I can control the people
according to my will. If you've seen the
other stuff on the channel, folks, if
you watch the playlist titled The Cursed
Gospel of Adventism, specifically the
Second Angel's Message, this is
completely in line with everything else
Ellen said. All our pastors in our
churches, meaning Christian churches,
they're tools of Satan. The prayers are
an abomination. We're deceived. We're
following. That's the whole under
undertone that's going on here.
But our principal concern is to silence
this sect of Sabbathkeepers, Adventists.
We must excite popular indignation
against them. We will enlist great men
and worldly wise men upon our side and
induce those in authority to carry out
our purposes. Then the Sabbath which I
have set up shall be enforced by law as
the most severe and exacting.
Those who disregard them shall be driven
out from the cities and villages and
made to suffer hunger and privation.
When once we have the power, we will
show that we can do with those who will
not swerve from their allegiance to God.
We led the Roman church to inflict
imprisonment, torture, and death upon
those who refuse to yield to her
decrees. And now that we are bringing
the Protestant churches and the world
into harmony with this right arm of our
strength, we will finally have a law to
exterminate all who will not submit to
our authority. When death shall be made
the penalty of violating our Sabbath,
then many who are ranked with
commandment keepers will come over to
our side. But before proceeding to these
extreme measures, we must exert all our
wisdom and subtlety to deceive and
ensnare those who honor the true
Sabbath. We can separate many from
Christ by worldliness, lust, and pride.
They may think themselves safe because
they believe the truth, but indulgence
of appetite or the lower passions which
will confuse judgment and destroy
discrimination will cause their fall.
It's funny how Satan in in brackets here
is supposedly speaking and he talks like
Ellen White writes,
interestingly enough, but that's where
Mark's getting this from. It's not your
imagination, sir. Your imagination,
you're literally just reading through.
He's doing the same thing that a few
weeks ago when we reviewed Steven Boore,
same exact thing. He's literally
preaching from Patriarchs and Prophets,
pages 53 through 55. quoting
periodically and stating when he's
actually doing it, but he's literally
just going through the chapters of that
and then inserting the proof text that
Ellen does from the Bible to make it
look like it's biblical. Same thing
here.
As you can see, his imagination is him
just paring Ellen White because that's
what that was.
Imagination, fiction, fake, made up.
Nowhere does scripture say that the
Sabbath is the great question which is
to to decide the destiny of people's
souls.
Nowhere does scripture say Satan's
created his own Sabbath. This is all
Sunday boogeyman nonsense as we're going
to see. But this is the foundation of
this whole thing to try and position
thing like things like Christians are
following Satan. They're duped by the
devil and they need the Adventist
message to rescue them.
No biblical basis for worshiping on the
first day. It's a product of Satan.
Notice too what she said. She says Satan
scheming to attack the Adventist system.
How ironic.
He's strictly focused on the specific
Adventist distinctives. He's apparently
obsessed with Adventists, which is
really the vibe you'd get when growing
up in in Adventism. I heard more about
Satan in Adventism than anywhere else.
Constantly talking about Satan, all
these things about Satan. Satan, Satan,
Satan.
How convenient. He if you disagree with
the false doctrines of SDAs, it's
because of Satan. You reject the
investigative judgment, what they'll
often refer to as Christ's work in the
heavenly sanctuary. You're influenced by
Satan.
This is why Adventists think they're
insulated from any sort of critique.
It's just assumed they're right. And if
you take umbrage with it, oh, it's
because of Satan.
How convenient.
Imagine if Christians said this. If you
disagree with me, it's because of Satan.
Doesn't matter what you actually
believe. My prophet told me it's because
of Satan, so that settles it. It's just
totally ludicrous thinking.
It's the exact method actually that
Satan would use to keep somebody trapped
in a system and inhibit their critical
thinking.
This is all fanfiction.
An adaptation of John Milton's Paradise
Lost being passed off as coming from God
himself as some sort of secret insight
into things Satan's doing someplace in
the cosmos. Because that's who Ellen was
plagiarizing from was John Milton in
Paradise Lost. This is carried over here
into Spirit of Prophecy Volume 4, but
predominantly from Great Controversy.
But then he mentions the second thing
here. He he mentions worshiping the
creation more than the creator, which is
why I mentioned this earlier, almost
mirroring the language of Romans 1. I
know he didn't quote that, but
that's where that's at in scripture. And
it's just I don't want to go off on a
tangent on that, but
Mark, Christians don't worship Sunday. I
think that's I think that's part of one
of the fundamental problems, sir. You
you guys seem to think that like you
guys worship a day that means we worship
a different day.
We worship Jesus, sir, for starters,
not a day. But secondly, the silly
notion that because you go to church on
Sunday, then that means you worship the
sun is is exactly that. That's silly.
Like I guess Adventists worship Saturn
because they go to church on Saturday.
This is silly reasoning that only works
in English as well. I actually had a guy
from Egypt reach out this past week and
he was talking about this claim. He he's
leaving the Adventist church and he's
talking with an Adventist pastor over
there. And this is one of the things
this guy's exporting from America into
other regions.
And this guy, this Adventist pastor is
preaching this in Egypt. And this guy
brings up to me, he's like, "How exactly
does this work if you don't speak
English?" Because that that has nothing
to do with how you say Sunday in or the
first day in Arabic.
It it just it's such silly reasoning to
to think that that's what people are
doing. They're worshiping the sun
because they go to church on Sunday. Um,
for those that don't know, this is also
an ancient charge that people have
levied at the church for almost 2,000
years at this point. Mark is making an
identical argument here that the pagans
did against Christians. So let's look at
an example of this so you can see what
I'm talking about. We're going to look
at Tertullian early uh Eastern church
father 3rd century. He wrote his book to
the nations in part to refute pagan
heretics and their claims. And this was
one of them that Christians were
worshiping on the Sunday which was a
common vernacular then it I know in
English when you say the Sunday it
sounds differently than that's just the
same as them saying Sunday that
Christians worship on Sunday was akin to
them worshiping the sun. The pagans
tried using this as a defense for their
practices to try and say Christians are
no different than them. So in response
to that here's what Tertullian says.
quote, "Others of kinder disposition
imagine that the sun is the Christian
God." Interesting. They have observed
that when we pray, we face to the east
and we rejoice on the day of the sun. It
is most definitely your preference to
single out Sunday, the seventh day from
the sequence. Notice he also refers to
Sunday as the seventh day because
Churchonian rightly understood that
what's being said in the fourth
commandment is a pattern, not a specific
day. It is a pattern from a memorial.
We're going to get into all that. He
continues,
"It is most definitely your preference
to single out Sunday, the seventh day
from the se the sequence to refrain to
refrain from bathing at least until
evening. This is also your designated
day for leisure and festivity. By doing
this, you depart from your traditional
practices in favor of alien religions.
The Jewish festivals are the Sabbath and
the feast of purification. And the Jews
also have the right of lamps and a
fasting with unleven bread and prayers
at the seashore. All of which are alien
to your gods. Now to return to our
subject, you who deride us for sun
worship and Sunday worship. See how
close you are to us. We are not far
removed from your Saturn and your
Sabbath.
Don't confuse worship on Sunday with
worshiping the sun god. That was
Tertullian's entire point. And he even
chastises them by saying, "You guys,"
talking about the pagans, "Depart from
your traditional practices in favor of
other religions." He calls these pagan
pagan practices their own type of
Sabbath. So essentially, while the
pagans criticized the Christians for
something and even the Jews for
something, they themselves were
borrowing the thing they were
criticizing.
Huh? Who does that sound like a
modern-day depiction of
anyways?
Mark is ultimately poisoning the well
here. He's using ancient pagan arguments
against Christians to set the stage for
the climax of the presentation because
it can't possibly be that Christians for
2,000 years have understood biblically
why the church universally worships
together on the first day. No, no, no.
It has to be because of some grand
conspiracy that Satan held a secret
board meeting in a dark corner of the
universe somewhere that Ellen White was
supposedly given insight to or he was
scheming to attack Adventists because
they go to church on a certain day.
That's the far more logical conclusion,
right?
If you're wondering why I'm laughing and
mocking, because it's worthy of that,
folks, this is a joke. Satan held a
secret board meeting in outer space.
It it just that's the reason why we
worship on Sunday. I'm sorry, but no, I
don't take that very seriously. And it
deserves that sort of response. kind of
like Elijah mocking the gods of Bahal
when they're doing their crazy dances
and nonsense and he says, "Is your God
on the toilet? Is that why he's not able
to respond to you?" It's like it's not
worthy of that. Satan's apparently
deceived all professing Christians and
we're in his clutches
yet. These are the same people, too,
that will wonder why Christians don't
embrace them and often play victim when
you challenge them on it. Gee, I wonder
why.
She said, "The people accept their
ministers explanations of scripture and
do not investigate for themselves." So,
it isn't just that we're deceived.
Notice that. But the scriptures are what
are doing the deceiving. Ministers are
using the scriptures to deceive people.
So, make up your mind, Adventists. Which
one is it? They'll say there's no
biblical basis at all for worship on
Sunday, but then say stuff like this.
The scriptures are used, but it's a
twisting of them to trick people who are
too lazy to study it for themselves.
This is slander and false witness. by
the way. But hey,
attributed to God too.
But also the irony, this is the
Adventist church to a tea. They have a
completely foreign worldview to the
Bible, i.e. the great controversy
paradigm.
They then teach that extra biblical
narrative and sprinkle in biblical proof
texts periodically that don't say a
fraction of what they are teaching. But
because they quoted a couple proof
texts, that makes everything they're
saying biblical.
But it's Christian pastors who are using
the Bible to deceive people. Yeah. Okay.
They always have this mindset about
Christians that they only reject the
novel Adventist Sabbath teaching because
they haven't had it presented to them.
This is what they'll say when you ask if
only seventh day Sabbath worshiping
Adventists will be saved. They'll say
no. But typically they mean others are
saved in ignorance. That's why. It's
because they haven't had the Sabbath
truth truth revealed to them. But as
you're going to see tonight, the
ignorance is on the SDA side because no
one was confused on the Sabbath prior to
the SDA church incorporating in the
1860s or even in the 1840s when Joseph
Bates claimed to get this the truth of
the Sabbath light, etc.
The SDA church revived all sorts of
beliefs that died for specific reasons.
They're literally just a cornucopia of
that. They just other than the
investigative judgment, they just
ascribe it to conspiracy and outlandish
ideas to try and bolster their novel
doctrine. We will get into the biblical
reasons for those that are just joining.
Um if you missed the intro for why
Christians meet on the first day in a
bit. No, it isn't single proof text
either like Acts 27 though that clearly
shows preaching in Eucharist taking
place on the first day which
demonstrates such activities isn't
demonic in origin from a satanic council
held in the back alley of the Milky Way
or wherever. Um tonight we're going to
look at large swaths of scripture and
motifs found all throughout the Old
Testament showing that the biblical
narrative regarding the Sabbath is
pointing somewhere. It's linear. It's
not just a static thing where you just
look at like one point the Adventist
church loves to just hone in on Exodus
or hone in and miss the whole narrative
of what's what's truly going on here. So
the irony of all of this is that the
charge is that Christians have no basis
for worshiping on Sunday. Yet Adventists
apparently have a biblical basis for a
secret council Satan held in the
universe to figure out how to attack
Adventist. So how ironic. But he
continues. Then he proceeds to his
second objective in the early Christian
in the early Christian centuries.
He blends sun worship with Christianity.
And so the church and state unite and in
honor of the resurrection so-called sun
worship comes into the church and begins
to replace the Sabbath.
Okay.
[Music]
All right, this is 100% patently false.
Mark, you get a D minus for even turning
this homework in. Bariting Ellen White
and Adventist pioneer JN Andrews instead
of doing your own homework, sir. So,
we're going to camp out here for a good
minute, folks. So, get comfortable.
There's a lot we have to unpack and
unravel. I know that was a short clip,
but they'll make these wild claims and
just move along as if it's fact. So,
we're going to take the time to address
this with the receipts. So, much of the
core Adventist system is built upon
these historical revisionisms. So, we
need to address that. For starters, like
I said, he is regurgitating what Ellen
White claimed in the great controversy
and elsewhere that Constantine was the
way by which the melding of Christianity
and sun worship took place, referring to
Constantine's edict of Milan and later
Pope Sylvester. Like I mentioned as
well, he is also paring and this is
where most SDAs are getting this from
because he was so early on in the
movement and he was getting it from
Ellen White. He is paring Adventist
pioneer JN Andrews book history of the
Sabbath verbatim.
Andrews was the foremost SDA Sabotarian
theologian of the pioneers. I've heard
SDAs regurgitate this book uh probably a
thousand times at this point. So let's
look at a section of it and notice what
he asserts here. Again, this is Jay and
Andrews, his book, The History of the
Sabbath. Okay, let's read a small
section here and see what he says.
So, I'm going to start here where it
says, "We have proved."
He says, "We've proved that the Sunday
festival in the Christian church had no
sabbatical character before the time of
Constantine." Okay, get that? Meaning,
it wasn't seen as a rest day.
He continues, "We've also shown that
heathenism in the person of Constantine
first gave to Sunday its sabbatical
character and in the very act of doing
it designated it as a heathen and not as
a Christian festival. This establishing
a heathen Sabbath.
It was now part of po It was now the
part of pop uh popery authoritative
sorry it was now the part of popery
authoratively to affect its
transformation into a Christian
institution a work which was not slow to
perform. Sylvester was the bishop of
Rome while Constantine was emperor. He
faithfully how faithfully he acted his
part in transforming the festival of the
sun into a Christian institution
is seen in that by his apostolic
authority talking about Sylvester he
changed the name of the day giving it
the imposing title of Lord's day
so Sylvester Pope Sylvester
gave the the Sunday the title Lord's day
to Constantine and Sylvester therefore
the advocates of first day observance
are greatly indebted.
The one elevated it as a heathen
festival to the throne of the empire,
making it a day of rest for most kinds
of business. The other changed it into a
Christian institution,
giving it the dignified appellation of
Lord's day.
Sorry folks, I just realized too that
this was not uh over for you all the
way. Sorry about that.
I'm going to start back where he says
the other the other changed it into a
Christian institution giving it the
dignified appellation of Lord's day. It
is not a sufficient reason for denying
that Pope Sylvester not far from AD 325
authoritatively conferred on Sunday the
name Lord's Day.
to say that one of the fathers as early
as AD 200 calls the day by that name and
that some seven different writers
between AD 200 and AD 325. Tertullian
origin, Cyprien, Anatolius,
Commandius, Victorinus, Marius
Victorinus and Peter of Alexandria can
be aduced who give this name to Sunday.
Fgrade do not pass go do not collect
$200 straight to jail.
Constantine did not enact a heathen
Sabbath or a heathen festival. And you
know it's funny he mentions origin. He
mentions a number of church fathers
there. But he mentions origin here after
saying it was Constantine that gave the
first day its sabbatical character
because this is straight up false.
Origin can be referenced to show he
never used the term Lord's day as well.
Well, no. I think actually in there he
says that they could be aduced because
cuz they did.
But notice what origin says here. This
is from his homalies 23 and numerous 4
which was written in 220 AD. So over a
hundred years before Constantine and
Sylvester. Okay, this is in reference to
J and Andrews saying we've proved that
the Sunday festival in the Christian
church had no sabbatical character
before the time of Constantine. Okay.
What does origin say?
on Sunday. None of the actions of the
world should be done.
If then you abstain from all the works
of this world and keep yourself free for
spiritual things, go to church, listen
to the readings and divine homalies,
meditate on heavenly things.
Can you make this stuff up, folks?
JN Andrews did not know what he is
talking about.
And this is the guy 90% of Adventists
are regurgitating whether they know that
or not.
It's just like
what?
And this is only one. You're gonna
you're going to see folks, this is not a
a one-off type thing here where it's
like, oh, origin was just some outlier.
But other question,
JN Andrew's entire premise, which is
that the seventh day Sabbath was still
being observed up until Constantine and
Sylvester.
In his book, Answers to the Jews,
Teroleian wrote this about the Jewish
Sabbath. This is written 150 years
before Constantine. Okay.
Quote, "It follows accordingly that in
so far as the abolition of carnal
circumcision and of the old law is
demonstrated as having been consummated
at its specific times, so also the
observance of the Jewish 7th day Sabbath
is demonstrated to have been temporary."
There's the reference for those that
want it. an answer to the Jews by
Tertullian roughly 200 ADund and some
odd years before Constantine was even
born.
But even so,
mentioning the church fathers are
pointing to the church fathers
as though
yeah there's there's these who could be
pointed to who who mention it prior to
Constantine and associate the Lord's day
with with Sunday, but it's still a
product of Sylvester.
What?
This is why, for those that don't know,
the SDA church has to assert ridiculous
stuff like Ignatius's letter to the
Magnesians from AD 110 that calls the
first day the Lord's day. That's a
forgery. It wasn't written by him. And
that the dedicay written in the first
century is talking about the Jewish
Sabbath when it uses the term Lord's
Day.
Since these usages far predate Sylvester
and Constantine,
they have to come up with some sort of
defense when in reality it was coming
from Revelation 110. But they can't have
this or the narrative collapses. So they
try and use the forgery argument. You
know, speaking of that, let's now look
at chapter 14 of the dedicay, which uses
the term Lord's Day,
one of the earliest sources that we
have.
again written hundreds of years before
Constantine was even born before
Sylvester is even born. For those don't
that don't know the dedicay was compiled
uh it was a compiled document laying out
essentially what the the church believed
universally and by universally we mean
in the east and the west. So what does
it say regarding the Lord's day? But
every Lord's day, gather yourselves
together and break bread and give
thanksgiving after having confessed your
transgressions that your sacrifice may
be pure. That's dedicate chapter 14.
And then right below it actually is
Ignatius's letter to the Magnesians as
well, which is the other thing they say,
"Oh, it's a forgery." What does he say?
We're going to look at this in fuller
context um a little bit later, but he
says, "Those who were brought up in the
ancient order of things, meaning the
Jews, have come to the possession of a
new hope, no longer observing the
Sabbath, but living in the observance of
the Lord's day,
of which also our life has sprung up
again by him and by his death." This is
what we are going to end up expounding
upon tonight, but that's later to the
Magnesians. Number nine, AD 110. But
because he contrasts the Lord's day here
to the Sabbath, they have to say, "Oh,
see it's it's it's it's a forgery."
Don't don't don't look at that. Don't
trust that with the dedicay. Well, it
doesn't mention the Jewish Sabbath. So
there they say, "Oh, it's talking about
the Jewish Sabbath."
But regardless of who wrote the epistle
to the Magnesians or the dedicay, the
fact that we have these original source
documents predating Constantine and
Sylvester show that the phrase was
already being used long before this
historical revisionism of Jane Andrews.
But also, sir, please make up your mind.
Adventists, make up your mind if you're
using these arguments. If you're an
Adventist apologist,
to deal with the fact that the dedicay
far precedes Pope Sylvester, the
Adventist church and her apologists will
say the usage of the phrase Lord's Day
in the dedicay is referring to the old
creation 7th day Sabbath. Okay. So, did
Sylvester supposedly coin the term in
the 4th century as a deceptive tactic
like JN Andrews claims? Or did the
dedicay use it to refer to the Jewish
Sabbath? Like, hello, you can't have it
both ways.
It's the Jewish Sabbath and the dedicay
which pre predates Sylvester by hundreds
of years. But also, Sylvester coined the
term as a deception of the fake Sabbath
that Satan instituted. Huh.
Okay.
And SDA leadership will still parrot
this guy regardless.
But with regards to Sunday being more
revered than it had been, another thing
they try to point to to claim
Constantine gave Sunday its sobatical
character. Uh, duh. You think
the edict made it legal in the Roman
Empire. That's the key word, legal in
the Roman Empire to be a Christian. And
this is after hundreds of years of first
p fierce persecution. I mean, come on.
You're talking about going from
Christians being used as crucified
garden torches
to being able to come out of hiding in
the largest, most powerful empire on the
globe at the time. Obviously, that's
going to have an impact. That doesn't
prove that anything changed as we're
going to see. Christianity was illegal
at this time.
Constantine's edict recognized and made
it legitimate.
It didn't change anything about the day
of that the church was worshiping on.
It recognized what was already a present
reality.
reality. Christians were already
worshiping on Sunday.
And Constantine's edict had to do with
civil recognition, not religious. And
this is vitally important. And we're
going to look at this again shortly.
They also failed at mention that this
edict only had jurisdiction over the
Roman Empire which was not a one world
government. They didn't have complete
control of the entire planet. The gospel
had already gone out to the east and
they were already worshiping on the
first day too. That's where Tertullian
was.
But I want to look at at Philip Schoff's
history of the Christian church book
three. For those that don't know, Dr.
Dr. Scha was a renowned church historian
that even the SDA church frequently
cites like in their 28 fundamental
beliefs book. But I want to look at a
couple of things that Dr. Schoff says in
light of what JN Andrews and Mark Finley
have claimed.
Notice what he documents down here about
Sunday and the Sabbath. To start, me get
this world up here.
Okay.
So, notice what he starts off by saying,
the blue highlight.
The observance of Sunday originated in
the time of the apostles and ever since
forms the basic or basis of public
worship with its enabling, sanctifying
and cheering influences in all Christian
lands. So halt
from the time of the apostles,
not Sylvester the pope, not Constantine,
not the council of Leadyia, the
apostles.
The Adventist church loves quoting
Philip Scha. And as you're going to see,
we're going to look at something one of
their SDA pioneers said regarding Shaw
that apparently he hadn't read enough
because what he was saying puts him in a
catch 22. But Sha continues. He says,
"The Christian Sabbath is on the one
hand the continuation and the
regeneration of the Jewish Sabbath based
upon God's resting from the creation and
upon the fourth commandment of the
Decalogue,
which as to its substance is not of
merely national application like the
ceremonial and civil law, but of
universal import and perpetual validity
for mankind. It is on the other hand a
new creation of the gospel, a memorial
of the resurrection of Christ and of the
work of redemption completed and
divinely sealed thereby.
It rests, we may say, upon the
three-fold basis of the original
creation, the Jewish legislation, and
the Christian redemption,
and is rooted in the physical, the
moral, and the religious wants of our
nature. It has a legal and an
evangelical aspect. Like the law in
general, the institution of the
Christian Sabbath is a wholesome
restraint upon the people and a school
master to lead them to Christ. But it is
also strictly ev uh but it is also
strictly evangelical. It was originally
made for the benefit of man like the
family with which it goes back beyond
the fall to the paradise of innocence as
the second institution on of God on
earth. It was a delight to the pious of
the old dispensation and now under the
new. It is fraught with the glorious
memories and blessings of Christ's
resurrection and the outpouring of the
Holy Spirit. The Christian Sabbath is
the ancient Sabbath baptized with fire
and the Holy Ghost regenerated,
spiritualized, and glorified. It is the
connecting link of creation and
redemption. That is key. Then we're
going to look at this tonight. We've
talked about this some on the channel,
but we're going to go real deep on this
tonight.
It is the connecting link of creation
and redemption of paradise lost and
paradise regained and a pledge in
preparation for the saints everlasting
rest in heaven. Close quote.
So Dr. Schauff rightly points out that
the first day is the memor the memorial
of the new creation.
The Jewish 7th day Sabbath was the
memorial of the old fallen creation that
needed to be redeemed.
that actually typified meaning it
pointed to the new creation and eternal
rest.
Once Jesus accomplished redemption by
his resurrection, which demonstrated the
completion of the work of redemption,
the new creation was inaugurated.
God is currently making people new
creatures in Christ. 2 Corinthians 5:17.
This means he is presently working on
the new creation because we are a part
of the new creation.
This is where the tie of the
resurrection comes in that Mark
erroneously and said in the name of the
resurrection so cold to try and downplay
this acting like this has no correlation
to the topic which again proves he
doesn't even understand what he's
criticizing he's just paring the SDA
pioneers regarding Pope Sylvester
but now Shave is going to talk about the
edict of Milan
what does he say here
so long as Christianity was not
recognized and protected by the state.
The observance of Sunday was purely
religious,
a strictly voluntary service, but
exposed to continual interruption from
the bustle of the world and a hostile
community.
The pagan Romans paid no more regarding
the Christian Sunday than the Jewish
Sabbath.
Close quote.
Did you get that?
prior to the edict when Christianity was
illegal.
Sunday observance was strictly
religious.
This is because it was already happening
and already taking place.
But I'm emphasizing this because there
is another aspect and that's where
Constantine was involved. It was not the
religious aspect.
But notice too, the pagans paid no more
regard for the Lord's day than the
Jewish Sabbath. The pagans did not care.
Christian worship on Sunday was not
about a pagan holiday like the Adventist
church claims, some pagan holiday for
the sun gods that Christians then
adopted. This is total fiction. Total
fiction.
He continues
in this matter as in others
the assession of Constantine marks the
beginning of a new era and did good
service to the church and to the cause
of public order and morality.
Constantine is the founder in part at
least of the civil observance of Sunday
by which alone the religious observance
of it in the church could be made
universal and could be properly secured.
In the year 321 he issued a law
prohibiting manual labor in the cities
and all judicial transactions. At a
later period also military exercises on
Sunday he exempted the liberation of
slaves which as an act of Christian
humanity and charity might with special
propriety take place on that day. But
the Sunday law of Constantine must not
be overrated.
He enjoined the observance or rather
forbade the public desecration of
Sunday,
not under the name of Sabbatham or Das
Domini, but under its old astrological
and heathen title, Das Solus,
familiar to all his subjects, so that
the law was as applicable to the
worshippers of Hercules, Apollos, and
Mithris, as to the Christians. Now, this
is where they're going to point to and
say, "See, yeah, see, he named it after
that because he was melting Listen,
there is no reference whatsoever in his
law either to the fourth commandment or
to the resurrection of Christ. Beside,
he expressly exempted the country
districts where paganism still prevailed
from the prohibition of labor and thus
avoided every appearance of injustice.
Christians and pagans had been
accustomed to festival rests. Now get
this.
Constantine made these rests to
synchronize and gave the preference to
Sunday on which day Christians from the
beginning celebrated the resurrection of
their Lord and Savior.
This and no more
was implied in the famous enactment of
3:21.
Close quote.
So there was a civil and religious
observance, two entirely different
things.
The civil had to do with the legalities
around what the government did and did
not recognize.
That was not the religious aspect which
the church was already practicing.
This civil observance had to do with the
empire recognizing Christianity as a
valid and legal religion.
Notice what the encyclop encyclopedia
bratannica says
regarding the edict of Milan here.
It's perfectly in line with what Sha
said in more detail. JN Andrews actually
cites the Encyclopedia Bratannica.
It's in his book to bolster the idea
that the Bratannica is on their side.
But notice what it says about it.
Edict of Milan proclamation that
permanently established religious
toleration for Christianity within the
Roman Empire. It was the outcome of a
political agreement concluded in Molanum
modern-day Milan between the Roman
emperors Constantine 1 and Linus in
February 313. The proclamation made for
the east by Lenus in June 313 granted
all persons freedom to worship whatever
deity they pleased, assured Christians
of legal rights, including the right to
organize churches, and directed the
prompt return to Christians of
confiscated property. Previous edicts of
toleration had been as short-lived as
the regimes that sanctioned them. But
this time the edict effectively
established religious toleration. The
extent copies of the decree are those
posted by license in the eastern parts
of the empire.
It established religious toleration
folks. That was the heart of it. which
is a sheer case of irony
because one of the other big boogeymen
that the SDA church loves to claim is
that there's a war on this precise
thing, religious toleration.
Everyone's supposedly getting prepared
to attack SDAs for their religious
freedom to go to church on Saturday.
Yet, this is precisely what the edict of
Milan secured for Christians was legal
protection from religious persecution.
The irony.
So Constantine enacted a law that
legally recognized Christianity
alongside the pagan religions of the
day. He makes no reference in the edict
to the Ten Commandments, changing the
fourth commandment, worshiping the sun,
etc. because the edict had nothing to do
with that. The two groups, pagans and
Christians, weren't even united. The
pagan Romans didn't have it have weekly
festivals. Their festivals were annual,
like a holiday, like Thanksgiving or
Christmas.
The Christian day was weekly, every
Sunday. And like Sha said, Constantine
made these two synchronize by giving the
preference to Sunday, the Christian day.
It was a civil action on his part. The
civil law required pagans to respect the
day Christians were worshiping. It was a
hostile envir environment for
Christians. So the point being it had
nothing to do with intermingling sun
worship of pagans into Christianity.
And notice what what did what did Scha
say?
The edict exempted the country districts
where paganism still prevailed. again
showcasing that pagans did not even keep
Sunday. They were exempt from this. If
it was something that pagans were doing
that Christians then adopted, that
wouldn't have been necessary.
This entire thing was about protecting
Christians and their day of worship. Not
changing it, not protecting pagans or
some pagan day, nor melding the two
together. And to the Adventists that
like to argue that Constantine
reverenced Sunday as a sacred day
because he revered Apollo, no. Sunday
was simply the astrological name of the
day. No different than Saturday being
related to Saturday. Had no religious
significance to worshiping Apollo.
Apollo wasn't worshiped on Sunday more
than any other weekday by the pagans.
In fact, as an example of this,
let's look quickly at two statements by
SDA pioneer EJ Wagner, who deceptively
quotes what we just read from Shaw.
Okay, this is from Wagner's book titled
The Origin and Growth of Sunday
Observance in the Christian Church.
First, I want to look at what he admits
and then watch how he twists what we
what was actually being said by Dr.
Schoff.
But notice this.
Get it brought back up here.
So he starts off by saying, quote, "Dr.
Schoff is justly esteemed as a man of
extensive learning and whose testimony
regarding facts no one would call into
question. He is a theologian and a warm
friend of Sundaykeeping, but his
theological relations have not prevented
his giving the facts into the first
Sunday law."
So Dr. Sha's testimony about this, no
one would call into question.
The same man who we just saw told us
that worshiping on Sunday originated
with the apostles,
that Constantine's edict cannot be
overrated and used to weasel in all this
extra conspiracy, that it was to protect
Christians, not a melding of paganism
with Christianity, etc.
Can't call the facts into question.
There you go. Who could who could
possibly call Sha's knowledge and facts
into question? a leading SDA pioneer,
folks, one of the most impactful
individuals on modern day SDA theology.
Now, for his maligning of of Dr. Sha's
book
he goes on he says he says talking about
sha
he enjoined the observance
or rather forbade the public desecration
of Sunday not under the name Sabbathom
or das domini but under its own
astrological or heathen title das solus
familiar to all his subjects so that the
law was as applicable to the worshippers
of Hercules Apollo and Mithris as to the
Christians and the quoting of Scha off.
Wagner continues, "And indeed it was
more applicable to the worshippers of
Hercules, Apollo, or Mithris than to
Christians, for it referred to heathen
and not at all to Christian worship.
Again, Dr. Schaef says quoting Schauff
now he enjoined the civil observance of
Sunday though not as deas domini but as
das solus in conformity to his worship
of Apollo and in company with an
ordinance for the regular consultation
of the Harris books 3:21
ends quoting from Sha
concerning its claim to be considered a
sacred day it is not necessary to add
much to what has already been said by
the writers quoted it would be
presumption in the extreme to claim that
God ever conferred any blessing or
sanctification directly upon it.
Schoff disagrees with you, Wagner, and
you just said who could call into
question his facts.
By a system of false reasoning, they try
to make out that the blessing that was
conferred upon the seventh day was
transferred to the first. But of course,
no scripture is ever quoted to justify
the claim. The authorities here given
say it was dedicated to the sun.
Is that what Sha said?
Did Sha say it was dedicated to the sun?
Is that why Das domini the the
astrological calendar was used?
Baloney
had everything to do, the edict had
everything to do with Christians and
protecting them, not the heathen. It
wasn't about dedicating the day of the
the day to the sun. Andrews is twisting
Shaw's words to say the exact opposite
of what he was saying.
The name simply had to do again with the
astrological calendar. Not because of
the pagans, not because of worshiping
the sun, not to meld Christianity with
worshiping the sun, or in Mark's words,
worshiping the creation.
His edict had nothing to do with
transference of anything from one day to
another, the ten commandments, etc.
We read the whole section of what Sha
had to say in regards to this.
He said it can't be overrated. It had
nothing to do with these conspiratorial
claims. He partially quotes Sha out of
context, only the portions that make it
appear like Schauff is agreeing with his
contortion when in reality that isn't at
all what Sha was saying.
And yet again, we have an SDA who is
completely clueless on why Christians
worship on the first day. You're not
even in the discussion.
I I mean to say something, no scriptures
ever quoted. Dead giveaway. Not even in
the dialogue.
Now what you mean is no single proof
text is used that verbatim says worship
on Sunday. The inconsistent standard
that they only employ on this topic
because if they use the same standard
with the health message, Ellen White,
the investigative judgment, probation,
the whole SDA system, it would implode.
We don't build theology off of single
proof texts, chapter and vision verses
or uh chapter and verse divisions that
were added in the 1500s. Mind you, that
isn't why they were added to build
entire systems of theology on single
verses.
We build theology by looking at the
whole of scripture on a matter from
Genesis to Revelation and get the full
picture.
Which is why the new creation argument
absolutely decimates the SDA Sabbath
teaching. Straight up nukes it out of
orbit.
We'll walk through it in a bit after we
finish showing how the the foundation is
faulty and inconsistent.
But are you seeing the twisting, folks?
Did you see that? This information is
all available online. You can go check
out the origin and growth of Sunday
observance in the Christian church by EJ
Wagner. And then go look up Schoffs. You
can get the PDF version of Schoff's
history of the Christian church. It's
volume three. And see how it adds up.
Adventists are sadly paring these
talking points of the pioneers that
they've had handed down to them whether
they know that or not. So to Mark's
claim that sun worship came into the
church by way of the church in the state
melding is regurgitating Jane Andrew's
book history of the Sabbath which is
erroneous on a number of fronts. No,
Christians were not worshiping the sun
by their faith being legally recognized
alongside pagans and the emperor giving
preferential treatment to one group over
the other. And then Pope Sylvester
supposedly took Constantine's Day of the
Sun worship and Christianized it by
giving it the title Lord's Day. Complete
fiction. The Lord's Day is coming from
Revelation 1:10. regardless of if you
agree with it or not, that's where it
was being that's what was being
referenced and appealed to prior to
Sylvester even existing.
And if the only argument you have is
those are all forgeries. Thank you for
concinged the point. Now, there is so
much more I could say on this, an entire
stream could be dedicated to it, but
we're not even 5 minutes into Mark's
video yet, and we're an hour in. And
again, like I said, we have a lot of
arguments and scripture to get at. So,
let's get back into his video here.
Now, Satan doesn't care how he traps
people as long as he traps them. So, he
will use a variety of deceptions.
Some in future generations would be
trapped in the scientific arguments that
the world evolved on its own rather than
any creator and millions would accept
that deception.
For others, Satan would keep them so
busy, so occupied with the things of
time, they'd forget the things of
eternity, and they would not keep the
Bible Sabbath.
But then Satan would come up with one of
his most brilliant deceptions,
one of his most sophisticated deceptions
for Christians.
He would say
that if you are saved by grace, it's not
necessary to keep God's law. Therefore,
the law of God is irrelevant.
Okay? Total nonsense. Total nonsense.
I've mentioned on the channel before how
Adventism is stuck in the 19th century
in a north uh northeastern American
mindset. And this is one of those
evidences. They attack this straw man
that the majority of Christians think
the law of God's irrelevant because
they're under grace. So Adventism was
born in a region with a large portion of
what you'd call Marshianites
because that's that that was the case.
Because that was the case, that meant
the entire world believed and looked
like their surroundings.
So they to this day still take this
approach and they need to get with the
times. This is their Antonyomian straw
man.
And they paint everyone with this. If
you disagree with them, you're you're
the Martianite. As if the majority of
Christians are Martianites. Do not take
the bait, folks. Do not take the bait.
Mark is attacking the ancient heresy of
Martianism, which is exactly that, a
heresy denounced as a heresy 1,500 years
ago.
1500 plus.
What they mean when they say this is
Christians disagree with our upholding
of the old fallen creation memorial of
the seventh day Sabbath. So therefore,
they think the law is irrelevant.
or because Christians don't agree with
our unlawful use of the law, our
teaching that the law justifies and
reconciles you to God, they think the
law is irrelevant. Nonsense.
We're not going down that rabbit hole
tonight, but just do digging on the
third and fourth centuries regarding
Martianism.
To attack or or to act like this is the
majority Christian view such that it's
one of Satan's greatest schemes is just
laughable. Laughable.
It's a giant scheme of Satan that
Christians memorialize the most
cataclysmic event in all of existence
where Jesus Christ, God in flesh,
accomplished the greatest act in human
history by redeeming the the creation
that fell. Inaugurating a new creation,
graciously allowing us to be a part of
his kingdom. Christians celebrating the
defeat of sin, Satan, and the grave on
the day that Jesus Christ accomplished
that is Satan's greatest scheme.
No, Christians have rightly understood
the law uh the law of God for nearly
2,000 years at this point.
The scheme of Satan is actually the
great apostasy, the falling away from
the teachings of Jesus and the gospel,
which is precisely what the Adventist
Church is a part of. That's his greatest
scheme. Getting you to accept anything
but the pure, unadulterated gospel and
clinging even one iod to anything other
than the person and work of the true and
living Christ.
That's the greatest deception of Satan.
Not going to church on a specific day.
Be we're going to get into all that. I
don't want to rant. Let's continue.
Satan would say that uh and this
probably would be his most dangerous
argument for believers. He'd introduce
the idea that a particular day makes no
difference at all as long as you
worship. He would distort the gospel and
make them believe that love does not
require obedience. Now all these
deceptions would have the common purpose
to discredit the Sabbath and discredit
the creator. But
so there you go.
Because people disagree with their old
creation memorial sabbath position that
means they hate the law of God. Words in
Adventism have completely different
meanings inside of the SDA shoe box of a
universe.
He says, "Satan has convinced people a
particular day makes no difference at
all." Again, more insight into how SDA's
worship a day completely missing the
substance.
No different than the wilderness wanders
led by Joshua, meaning Israel, who
failed to enter into God's rest due to
their unbelief, completely missing the
substance.
They were observing the old creation
memorial of the seventh day. Still
failed to enter into the rest, the text
says. But more on that later.
But Mark, the day is the memorial of the
substance. It is not the substance
itself.
You guys have infused a divine-like
characteristic to a 24-hour rotation
around the sun that has been labeled
Saturday, making it a divine,
unalterable, eternal, godlike thing.
Nowhere does the fourth commandment say
Saturday or Sunday or any specific day.
It is laying out a pattern which was
normative regarding much of the old
covenant.
It was patterns, types, and shadows that
were pointing to greater realities.
Israel was to meet every seven days from
the memorial to remember what the
memorial represented. The day was not
the substance.
You guys have no issue with this when it
comes to the investigative judgment. For
example, you guys all of a sudden become
masters of typology and things pointing
to greater realities when it comes to
the sanctuary. But then when it comes to
the Sabbath, oh no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. All of a sudden, nope, no
types, no shadow. The substance is a
24-hour rotation around the sun. God's
closed for worship on other days.
The substance of the Sabbath, folks, is
Jesus. How do we know this? because Paul
explicitly says so in Colossians 2
regarding the SDA or or regardless of
the SDA twisting of the text. The
substance is Jesus. The day is the
memorial. The question becomes, can the
memorial shift while still being a
memorial of the same substance? And the
answer is yes, which we will look at in
a bit comparing the old creation with
the new creation. But he also said that
Satan has distorted the gospel causing
people to think love doesn't require
obedience. Wow.
Wow.
The irony of this statement, sir, when I
first heard this, I I
I just I've heard this I don't know how
many times, and it just every time I
hear it, I'm just flabbergasted. Again,
it's like you do you not ever get out of
your bubble, sir.
The irony of the statement though is
that the Adventist church doesn't even
possess the gospel.
The Adventist Church is a part of the
great apostasy, a falling away from the
gospel.
Satan's confused people about the gospel
because the gospel has to do with what
day you're going to church because
that's the evidence that you truly love
God. Yet the irony is you guys don't
even understand the gospel.
This is again more straw manning of
using individual people who may say such
a thing as an example for the whole.
Yeah, you of course you can find some
kook out there. Go to that's why on this
channel we try to quote like official
Adventist source documentation or people
that have a a level of serious
understanding and authority, not just
Joe Schmo. If we're doing that, it's
because we're using them as an example
of something or responding to a comment,
but not broad brushing. We're trying to
go to primary Adventist source material,
their own published works, their own
scholars, their own theologians to hear
what they're saying. Do the same. Go to
the actual because what you're going to
see folks when we go to them later, none
of this stuff works on any of them. It
only works on people who are not
theologically astute or haven't studied
up on this or maybe are a babe in Christ
and they're still growing and learning.
There's a variety of reasons why. But
pointing to that individual to then say,
"See, so all non-SDAS is just
ridiculous." Mark, show us the major
Christian document that says anything
remotely close to this idea of others
don't believe in obedience. You're
attacking easy belieism style thinking,
another fringe minority, and saying this
is some major attack from Satan as if
it's the powerhouse thing. Again, sir,
show us the major Christian denomination
that teaches obedience has no part in
following Jesus. It's just about getting
your ticket punched for heaven. And once
that's done, there's no born again
experience in your life, no change, no
sanctification, etc. This straw man is
so old,
totally ridiculous, especially
considering people like myself. If you
wonder why I'm getting a little worked
up on this, radical conversion, life
radically changed, life physically
spared by the Lord Jesus Christ.
Radically changed by the gospel. But
because I disagree with their bunk
theology, it means I'm against
obedience.
Mark, people are against your guys'
false attributions to obedience. That
obedience is what maintains your
righteous standing before God, that
you're on probation, that the ball is in
your court to keep yourself saved.
But if you disagree with this, it's
automatically means you hate the law of
God, you don't want to obey Jesus, you
don't truly love Jesus, yada yada. How
convenient.
It can't ever be that SDA theology is
wrong. Nope. Impossible. It has to be
you're a fan of Christian anarchy and
rebellion. Again,
Mark, this trope is old and the longer
time goes on, the worse it's going to
get for SDA leadership who are keep
pariting this stuff because people are
going to come across our materials,
other people's materials who are doing
this, they're going to get the gumption
to actually go out there. I had a guy
reach out to me actually today about
this, might potentially come visit my
church with me. I hope he does. and
they're going to see it's nothing like
is is portrayed in this pseudo reality
of a shoe box called Adventism, the
bubble.
Christians are not against obedience,
sir. They're against your guys's faulty
teaching around obedience.
Why?
Why does the devil hate the Sabbath so
much? Here's the first reason. The devil
hates the Sabbath because it's a
memorial of creation and the devil hates
Jesus the creator. So if you have your
Bible, please take it and turn to
Genesis the 2 chapter.
Why does the devil hate the Sabbath so
much?
Because he wants to undermine creation.
And if he can undermine creation, he
knows he can discredit Jesus. And the
reason the devil hates the Sabbath is
because he hates the creator and he
hates Jesus. Genesis chapter 2. And
we're looking there at Genesis chapter 2
verse 1, 2, and three. Thus the heavens
and the earth and all the host of them
were finished. And on the seventh day,
God ended his work which he had done.
And he rested on the seventh day from
all his work which he had done. Now
notice carefully verse three. God
blessed the seventh day and sanctified
it. In it he rested from all his work
which God had created and made. So the
Sabbath was set aside at creation as a
memorial of God's love as a symbol of
God's care. But here is the question.
Who is it that blessed the Sabbath? Who
did that? Who is it that sanctified the
Sabbath? Who is it that rested on the
Sabbath? Now, although the Godhead
participated in creation, and you
remember God says, "Let us make man in
our image." So, the father, son, holy
spirit participated in creation. But,
but who was the active agent in
creation? Who was the actual creator?
Take your Bible and turn to Ephesians
3:9.
The father, son, and holy spirit
participate together. The father is the
active designer of the creative p of the
created world. But Paul tells us that
Jesus Christ himself
was the active agent in creation. So you
see the devil's strategy.
Okay. So he basically then just goes on
to read the verse and and continue off
of that claim that Jesus is the creator.
He sanctified the Sabbath. Um and then
reads a a verse from Ephesians. Mark,
you're right. The Sabbath is a memorial
of creation. Some folks might be shocked
to hear me say this, but he's right. I
agree. I actually give Mark a C on this
one. He even quotes Genesis 2 2-3, which
is what I often cite because that's what
Exodus 20:8 roots the Sabbath command
back in creation.
But it is so critically important in
this discussion, Mark, to distinguish
between two things. And you guys never
bring up this aspect when you're talking
about the Sabbath. I wonder why. The old
creation and the new creation.
This is the hinge upon which the
discussion takes place. You guys are so
used to dealing with the law was nailed
to the cross type arguments that when
the new creation's mentioned as being
relevant, you turn pale and unsure. I've
watched it.
I was just at Southern Adventist
University a couple weeks ago and and
brought this up to an Adventist pastor
and he turned pale. He had no answer. He
wanted to remain in contact. He'd never
heard this before.
Seventh Adventist theology has zero
concept around the new creation being a
present reality,
at least not on the general level. I've
read a few papers from their scholars
that recognize this, but they don't
realize the implications of it to their
system.
But the average SDA has no concept of
the new creation being a present
reality. It is a wholly future thing
that will be completely different than
the one we're in right now. God's going
to scrap this one by destroying it with
fire and then start a completely
different creation and port the saved
over into that creation by way of his
memory. Their personality and character
is going to be preserved in the mind of
God. A new body of entirely different
particles will be made. And then God
will implant that personality into the
new body so that you're recognizable.
This is not a true resurrection by the
way, but different topic for a different
day. The point is the idea in their
minds that the new creation has already
started is totally foreign.
And this is why they cannot grasp why
Christians worship on the first day and
not the seventh. It's why they will say
stuff like Christians have no biblical
basis for worshiping on Sunday. Show me
one verse that says that. Okay, remember
earlier they never cite a single Bible
verse. We're told by Jay and Andrews. We
can't s cite a single verse for this.
So, let's break this down, okay? We
aren't going to look at single proof
texts and just throw them out and say,
"See, as if that settles it." We're
going to engage in some biblical
theology here.
So, first things first, the Sabbath is
rooted in three things actually, not
just creation.
It's rooted in creation, rest, and
redemption.
Mark read Genesis 2 1-3, which mentions
creation and rest, which is also what
it's rooted in in Exodus 20:8.
The parallel to Exodus 20:8 is
Deuteronomy 5:12-15.
In that account, creation isn't
mentioned in Deuteronomy. Rest is, but
not creation. Instead, redemption is
mentioned.
It was to be observed by Israel as a
reminder of God bringing them out of
slavery in Egypt. All of these things,
folks, had larger typological things
that they foreshadowed.
So, three things, creation, rest, and
redemption.
Creation, rest, redemption.
Because of that, let's look at a number
of places in scripture regarding these
three topics. We're going to do a
systematic look and like I said, engage
in what's called biblical theology.
We're going to look at the whole of the
matter here. Not just jump in on one
little area and then just say, "So, see,
because it says this, that has to" No.
Engage in the narrative of where the
Bible is going. It's actually taking us
somewhere from Genesis to Revelation.
There's actually somewhere that we're
going.
We can't look at all of the the verses
tonight or we'd be here all night. So
this is just a sampling to see the
bigger picture regarding what's going on
here. We're going to start by focusing
on creation and rest. Then we will get
to looking at the redemptive aspect. And
then lastly, we will exede Hebrews 4
1-11, which ties all of this together so
perfectly.
So perfectly that the Lord God even put
a bow on it for us because that's
exactly what this chapter is in terms of
tying all this together for us.
But first, it's important to note that
God's ceasing from creation on the
seventh day was an indefinite thing. The
seventh day was not capped off with
evening and morning like the other days.
Not because there wasn't a close to that
day, but for a more significant reason
that we will see later.
God simply ceased from his work of
creation. He didn't cease from any and
all work entirely, but the act of
creation.
So, how do we know that he didn't cease
from work entirely? Well, because Jesus
tells us
in John five,
after Jesus heals the man at the pool
Bethesda on the Sabbath, the Jewish
leadership began to persecute him.
And down there,
notice what Jesus' response to them is.
So, because Jesus was doing these things
on the Sabbath, the Jewish leaders began
to persecute him. In his defense, Jesus
said to them, "My father is always at
his work to this very day, and I too am
working."
For this reason, they tried all the more
to kill him. Not only was he breaking
the Sabbath, but he was even calling God
his own father, making himself equal
with God. So, did you catch that?
In response to being a Sabbath breaker,
something Jesus was not, he tells the
Jewish leadership that the father is
always at work and Jesus himself was
working.
What ceased at creation was the act of
creating, but not work entirely.
But also notice, like I said, Jesus said
he was working. Working on what?
What was he working on?
because this work that he's mentioning,
he's actively doing on the Sabbath
in response to them telling them he's a
Sabbath breaker. He says, "Well, me and
my father have been at work."
You getting it, folks? There's more
going on to the Sabbath than just
looking at a day and and zooming in at a
certain period in history. We're going
somewhere.
Jesus was working on the redemption of
creation. That's what he came to do was
to seek and save that which was lost and
to redeem the creation that fell. He did
this by fulfilling all righteousness as
the Lord's servant that never sinned. He
kept the the the requirements of the
covenant of works or law perfectly.
Jesus was explaining this to them and
they missed it. So God in creation
ceased from creating. Not that he then
picked things back up the following day
and then followed that pattern himself
indefinitely. No, he created for six
days and then ceased and remained in
that restful state regarding creation
into the ninth day, 10th day or eighth
day, 9th day, 10th day and so on. That's
important because if you noticed, Mark
said God kept the Sabbath in creation.
No, he didn't. He sanctified what was
completed. He was done and was pleased
with his work in essence and he remained
in that state indefinitely. And there's
a reason why because even that typifies
and points to something.
So that's the first point. The seventh
day was not capped off with evening and
morning. And that is significant. God
ceased from the act of creating, but
he's been at work since then. Which
tells us there's something more going on
here than simply a 24 rotation around a
24-hour rotation around the sun. The
other thing to note about Genesis 2 2-3
is that the Sabbath was rooted in the
original pre-fallen creation.
I've used this this phrase old creation
and pre-fallen creation a number of
times tonight. So, in the vein of
looking at creation, let's establish
that the new creation is here and that
multiple places in scripture pointed to
the new creation, which would be a
redemption of the creation that fell.
Still in the theme of creation and
redemption here, folks. We're seeking to
round out our view on the subject in
light of all of scripture.
I've mentioned this on the channel
before, but we're going to look at
Leviticus 23 with regard to the feast of
first fruits. The Adventist Church
oftentimes downplays the feast,
festivals, etc., and misses the
substance of them in the process. They
were not merely cultural or arbitrary,
etc. Jesus is at the heart of all of it.
The first fruits is no different. I will
also preface by saying, Adventists, we
are looking at this to demonstrate the
new creation. Okay?
So before you get hyper in the comments,
that's the purpose of looking at this.
We are looking at the biblical narrative
to see where it is going, pointing to
specific things, etc. We're looking at
this to show a type that pointed to the
new creation to show that the new
creation has indeed started. That's the
purpose. I just I reiterate this because
I've engaged with a lot of you guys
before and I'm not saying this is an
insult. It's just a lot of times you
don't really understand or you don't
follow with what's being why something
is being cited. So this is being
referenced now to show that the new
creation
has started. That's the purpose of
looking at this now because again we're
on the topics of creation, redemption,
and rest.
So Leviticus 23:9-11.
People want to follow along. Leviticus
23 9-11.
talking about the feast of first fruits.
It says, "And the Lord spoke to Moses,
saying, speak to the people of Israel
and say to them, when you've come into
the land that I give you and reap its
harvest, you shall bring the sheath of
the first fruits of your harvest to the
priest, and he shall wave the sheath
before the Lord so that you may be
accepted. On the day after the Sabbath,
the priest shall wave it."
So, what were the first fruits?
audience.
What were the first fruits?
It was the new fruit that had just
grown, the ripest, nicest, cream of the
crop, best of the best. They were to be
gathered throughout the week and put
into a sheath. A sheath is a wrapping.
They were to do so before the seventh
day Sabbath where the fruit would stay
wrapped until the day after the Sabbath
to then be brought out and presented
before the Lord who would accept it.
Jesus Christ is the first fruits as Paul
tells us and we will look at
momentarily.
He's the cream of the crop, the best of
the best. Just like Israel was commanded
to work by gathering the first fruits
throughout the week and then let them
rest in the sheath on the Sabbath. So
Jesus worked for our redemption. He was
wrapped in burial clothes just like the
sheath of fruit and was in the tomb
until the first day where he came out of
the wrapping and was presented before
the father as the first fruits of the
resurrection of a new creation.
Not just that, but the first fruits were
a picture of new creation.
And this is precisely what Paul gets at.
So let's look at Paul's application and
understanding of the antitype of the
first fruits with regard to Jesus and
new creation. So speaking about the
resurrection, 1 Corinthians 15 20-23.
1 Corinthians 15
20 through 23.
So this is after he has said if Christ
has not been raised or uh no that's
actually in second Corinthians. I can't
remember if that that's actually before
this or in 2 Corinthians because we're
going to look there next. No, it is here
because he says, "If Christ has not been
raised, our faith is in vain."
So then he he continues by saying, "But
in fact Christ has been raised from the
dead, the first fruits of those who have
fallen asleep.
For as by a man came death, by a man has
come also the resurrection of the dead.
For as in Adam all die, so also in
Christ shall all be made alive, but each
in his own order. Christ the first
fruits
then at his coming those who belong to
Christ.
So the first fruits also signified
resurrection newness of life.
This is how redemption is tied into this
as well. Christ was the first fruits of
the resurrection. Is Paul just using
poetic language here? Of course not.
He's writing to believers who would have
known the Old Testament. That was their
Bible of the day.
The canon was still open, but the old
can Old Testament cannon at that point
was closed. So they had more than likely
the Septuagent, the Greek translation of
the Hebrew Bible.
They would have caught the imagery
perfectly. Jesus was the best of the
best, cream of the crop, the very first
to raise from the dead, but also a
picture of the new creation.
When the antitype of that shadow was
fulfilled at the resurrection, it
ushered in the new creation. How do we
know this? Well, because Paul explains
in 2 Corinthians 5:16-19.
So Paul is explaining the ministry of
reconciliation here.
That's the overarching context. He's
talking about the ministry of
reconciliation that's been entrusted to
believers through Christ. And this is
again tying redemption into creation.
Reconciliation has to do with redemption
just like resurrection does. But notice
what Paul says.
From now on, therefore, we regard no one
according to the flesh. Even though we
once regarded Christ according to the
flesh, we regard him thus no longer.
Therefore, if anyone is in Christ, he is
a new creation. The old has passed away.
Behold, the new has come. All this is
from God, who through Christ reconciled
us to himself, and gave us the ministry
of reconciliation. that is in Christ,
God was reconciling the world to
himself, not counting their trespasses
against them and entrusting to us the
message of reconciliation.
So notice we have a contrast between an
old and new creation. Jesus Christ is
the first fruits of the resurrection and
the new creation.
Those that are in him will follow order
after him in resurrection. But Paul also
explains that those who are in Christ
are presently new creatures.
The old is gone, new has come. Present
tense. This is not merely behavior
modification. Yes, that does happen.
But that's the fruit, not the root. The
root of the new behavior is being a new
creature, a new creation.
This is the work that God is doing
currently. Jesus says this from his
throne. Revelation 15, behold, I am
making all new things, no, all things
new.
And he's presently making people new
creatures in Christ.
And since we are a part of the creation
and God is presently doing this, that
means the new creation has already
begun.
He's presently making new creatures in
Christ. And we're a part of the creation
and we'll be a part of the new creation.
We haven't gotten our glorified. The
glorification of our bodies hasn't
happened yet.
But did you catch that? Just like Jesus
says, Revelation 21:5, he's presently
making all things new. Not all new
things, but all things new. The new
creation process has already started.
Meaning, the new creation is already
here. It's just not in its fullness yet.
The curse hasn't been lifted off the
creation, for example. It's still
groaning.
And where am I getting this? Let's look
at what else Paul says about first
fruits and new creation in Romans 8,
which really ties in as well,
redemption.
And if you're just joining us, folks, we
are doing a systematic look at the
topics of creation, rest, and
redemption, which is what the Sabbath is
rooted in. In a bit, we're going to look
at Hebrews 4, which ties all this
together for us beautifully. But Romans
8:18-24,
Paul's talking here about the future
glory that awaits believers, the joy and
hope we have in Christ that we long to
see come to full fruition, the
resurrection of the body, the curse
placed on the creation in Genesis 3
lifted, etc. So Romans 8 18- 24
Romans 8 18- 24
he says
whoops for I consider
that the sufferings of the present time
are not worth comparing with the glory
that is to be revealed to us. For the
creation waits with eager longing for
the revealing of the sons of God. For
the creation was subjected to futility,
not willingly, but because of him who
subjected it, in hope that the creation
itself will be set free from its
bondage, to corruption, and to obtain
the freedom of the glory of the children
of God. For we know that the whole
creation has been groaning together in
the pains of childbirth until now. And
not only the creation, but we ourselves
who have the what?
First fruits of the spirit.
We grown inwardly as we await eagerly
for the adoption as sons, the redemption
of our bodies. For in this hope we were
saved. Now hope that is seen is not
hope.
For we hope for what he sees or for who
hopes for what he sees. But if we hope
for what we do not see, we wait for it
with patience. So what does Paul say
here about creation?
that the creation was subjected to
futility due to the doings of man. Man
is a part of the creation, but he had
dominion over it. That was a command
from God. And he plunged it into bondage
and corruption such that the creation is
groaning and longing for the day that
the curse is lifted off of it. And we
that have the first fruits of the spirit
are groaning as well, waiting for this
to happen when we receive our glorified
body. Again, first fruits, new creation,
present reality.
This is how we can presently be new
creatures in Christ. By the way,
Paul just got done before in Romans 8
here in Romans 7 talking all about the
new man and the old man and how the new
man, the spirit, wars with the old man,
the flesh. We are awaiting the day that
the body is resurrected and glorified
such that that war doesn't happen
anymore. That is part of the future
glory that we await. That's why we're
longing for it. Are you longing to be
out of your body that aches and and
needs to it breaks down and
yeah, we want the curse lifted off the
creation and for our bodies to be
glorified. That's the glory that we're
longing for to be in complete perfect
union with our creator.
But our new inner man will carry over
into that resurrected glorified body
which again means we are new creatures
presently and the new creation is
already underway. God isn't going to
completely discard this creation and
start a completely different one. If
that were the case, we would be scrapped
because we are a part of the present
creation.
So with all that said, and we could keep
going on on creation, but I think you
get the point. The new creation has
presently started. It is a present
reality.
And the new creation has a new memorial.
It is not the same as the old memorial.
The Exodus account teaches us the
creational aspect of the Sabbath.
Deuteronomy shows us the redemptive
aspect. The old creation of which the
seventh day was a memorial sign was a
type and shadow of the new creation that
was inaugurated with the resurrection of
Christ. And deliverance from slavery in
Egypt was a type and shadow of our
redemption and freedom from slavery to
sin which Christ delivers us from
through his finished work of atonement.
We also know that from multiple New
Testament passages that the gospel is
Christ's work for us. Like I like we
looked at in passing earlier, Christ has
been working his perfect life, death,
burial, and resurrection. That was the
work of redemption.
When Christ finished that work, we're
told he sat down at the right hand of
God. Hebrews 10:12, which was signifying
that the work was finished. Just like
the Levitical priest worked to redeem
redeem from sin, so did Christ. But
unlike them, he sat down, something they
never did because the work of dealing
with sin was never finished.
This is fundamentally why the Christian
church worships every seven days from
the new memorial and why people point to
the resurrection as the basis for it.
Even if they may not understand all the
details around it. It's not just
arbitrarily because well Jesus
resurrected.
No, that resurrection represented
Christ's accomplished work of our
redemption ushering in a new creation,
the first fruits which brought with it a
new memorial.
So now let's look at how Jesus's work of
redemption parallels God's work in
creation. both the working and resting
or ceasing if you will which completely
ties all of this together and some of
the psalms and even back to Leviticus
we see the new creation is inaugurated
it has started. So now we need to look
at how this new creation is marked by a
new memorial signified by a new day and
there is a reason for that and God
typologically foreshadowed this for us
all throughout the Old Testament. We are
only going to scratch the service here.
But first, I want to go back to
Leviticus 23 where we have holy worship
acts taking place in the Old Testament
on the first day and are called and the
8th day. And they're called holy in the
same chapter of Leviticus we were just
in. And I'll tell you why I want to
quote this really quick just to get
ahead of something that's often charged.
Leviticus 23:35-36.
It says, "On the first day shall be a
holy convocation.
You shall not do any work. For seven
days, you shall present food offerings
to the Lord. On the eighth day, you
shall hold a holy convocation and
present a food offering to the Lord. It
is a solemn assembly. You shall not do
any ordinary work."
The Old Testament foreshadowed holy
worshipful acts taking place on the
first or eighth day constantly. And yes,
Adventists, I know it doesn't say
Sunday,
that the weekday could have varied. That
is not the point of what's being said.
The claim is that
or the claim is not that because it says
first day, that means Sunday. Call the
first day whatever you want. Purple day.
The name is irrelevant. It's only
relevant to SDAs who think the name
Sunday is intrinsically tied to the
worship and it isn't.
These holy worship days could have
fallen on any day of the week based on
where they were in their calendar cycle.
So that means what was holy about it
wasn't intrinsically tied to the name of
a specific day
or a specific rotation around the sun.
It was the pattern that God had given
them and obeying God. That's what was
important,
which I understand Adventists think
they're doing that.
But interestingly enough, we're going to
get into Hebrews 4 1- 1-11 here, and I
think you're going to see that there's a
bit of of sad irony here. But the point
of this is a foreshadowing of the first
day or the eighth day, the day after the
Sabbath, having holy, worshipful acts
taking place on it. Just like we saw
with the sheath of the first fruits, it
was presented before the Lord on the day
after the Sabbath. That's the
resurrection, the day after the Sabbath.
So, sorry to the folks that want to say
Jesus resurrected on Saturday. Um,
that's not according to the the first
fruits,
but the first day, that's when the new
creation was inaugurated. Here we see,
like I said, holy, worshipful acts that
God calls holy on a day other than the
seventh day Sabbath.
So, we looked at that just in in preface
here because the Adventist church loves
to say God only ever made one day holy,
the seventh,
to which they import Saturday into that
isn't true. They're missing the point
entirely. God used patterns as a way to
teach things to Israel. He does this
with countless other things. The subject
is no different. So now I want to look
at and we're going to spend quite a bit
of time on this one because again this
is the most compact succinct rich
topic of this want to look at Hebrews 4
1-11
remember creation rest redemption we've
looked at Jesus's work of redemption
that he's doing a work of redemption or
was doing a work of redemption and
accomplished that work
that the new creation has begun
The Sabbath was rooted in creation,
redemption, rest,
putting the the picture together here.
And this ties it together for us
perfectly. But before we read, let's lay
some groundwork.
Look at verse one.
We're going to go to four and then we'll
have to reference three.
Look at verse one. The first thing that
he exhorts us to do, we're going to read
all this, by the way, folks. Uh just
like I said, I want to lay some some
groundwork here. The first thing that he
exhorts us to do, he wants to make sure
we do not fail to enter into the rest,
which immediately should cause us to
ask, okay, what rest? Then in verse two,
there were some that had the gospel
preached to them, but didn't enter into
this rest.
Using Israel as an example for the
reader,
but he still hasn't told us what the
rest is.
In verses 3 to 7, he begins the
explanation of what the rest is by
saying that there's a Sabbath rest that
remains for Christians.
That is the third part of the author's
argument.
But then in verse 8 to 10, he explains
that this rest that he's talking about
is not something that we fully
experience in this world.
We have a foretaste of it which he's
going to say the foretaste remains
but there's something that transcends
here that we have yet to enter into.
So we have a foretaste of it but it's
something that God doesn't fully give us
until Jesus comes again. So there's an
esqueatological component to this rest
where this ultimate rest will will be
given to his people. Then in verse 11,
he exhorts us to enter into that rest
again. So he bookends it off. So the
whole point of this paricopy,
enter the rest. It is a solemn call.
That's the point here. So keep that in
mind. And we're going to see what that
is. So I'm going to read all the verses
now 1 through 11 and then we're going to
break this down and and chain it
together. Okay? So he says, "Therefore,"
showing us that this is connected back
to chapter 3. That's what the therefore
is there for.
While the promise of entering his rest
still stands, let us fear lest any of
you should seem to have failed to reach
it.
For good news came to us just as to
them, referring to Israel. But the
message they heard did not benefit them
because they were not united by faith
with those who listened. For we who have
believed enter that rest.
as he has said, "As I swore in my wrath,
they shall not enter my rest." Quoting
from the Psalms,
although his works were finished from
the foundation of the world, for he has
somewhere spoken of the seventh day in
this way, and God rested on the seventh
day from all his works. And again, in
this passage, he said, quoting from the
Psalms again, they shall not enter my
rest.
Since therefore it remains for some to
enter it and those who formerly received
the good news failed to enter enter
because of disobedience again he
appoints a certain day today saying
through David so long afterward in the
words already quoted today if you hear
his voice do not harden your hearts for
if Joshua had given them rest would not
have spoken of another day later on.
So then there remains a Sabbath rest for
the people of God. For whoever has
entered God's rest has also rested from
his works as God did from his. Let us
therefore strive to enter that rest so
that no one may fall by the same sort of
disobedience.
And thus the reading of God's holy and
inspired word.
So in verse one,
his point is simple. Don't fail to reach
the rest that remains. If you look at
the last words of Hebrews 3, chapter 3,
he quoted Psalm 95:11
in Hebrews 3:11. here
I swore in my wrath they shall not enter
my rest.
Then he said in 3:19
they were unable to enter
which begs the question enter what
the rest
and it was because of their unbelief
that they didn't enter.
So the picture in view is the children
of Israel in the wilderness, redeemed by
God through divine providence out of the
land of Egypt, brought across the Red
Sea, brought through the wilderness
through mighty miracles, ready to enter
the promised land. But then multitudes
of them end up dying in the wilderness.
Why?
They did not enter the rest. So with
that on the mind, his exhortation to the
reader, which is us, is he doesn't want
us to fail to enter the rest of God the
way that they failed to enter the rest
of God.
So he's using Israel as an illustration,
an example of what not to do.
Then in verse two, he gives a sharp
warning, a scary warning,
and that is that the gospel didn't
benefit those in the wilderness who
didn't believe.
We're going to hearken back to this
momentarily.
He says the good news came to them.
That's the gospel.
The gospel was preached to them just
like it's been preached to us. The
gospel is not unique to only the New
Testament.
When the Apostle Paul wants to explain
the gospel of justification by grace
alone, through faith alone, and Christ
alone, where does he what does he use to
support it in Romans 4? He takes us to
Genesis 15:6 where Abraham believed and
the Lord credited him as righteousness.
He goes right to the Old Testament to
preach justification by grace to us.
It's the same gospel that's been
proclaimed since Genesis 3:15. So,
Israel had the gospel preached to them
and didn't believe. Good news came to
them. God redeems them out of Egypt. He
was he he has made various promises to
them. Yet, his promises and redemption
did not benefit them.
They saw the mighty deeds of God right
before their eyes. They heard God's own
voice.
Yet they did not benefit from these
promises. Why?
Look at the end of verse two.
Because they were not united by faith to
those who listened. They didn't benefit
from the good news which was proclaimed
to them by God himself because they
didn't believe.
That was their fundamental failure.
So the rest that is in focus is one that
has to do with believing God. And
failure to believe God will keep one
from entering.
Which is why then
in verses 3 to 7 he goes on to say, "It
still remains for some to enter into
this rest."
He will tell us what that rest is in a
moment. But first, the author wants us
to understand that this is not just
something for Israel back there
somewhere in some ancient pastime
as if it doesn't really have anything to
do with us today. No, he's saying this
is an issue that's very pressing
presently.
And the fundamental question is, are we
going to enter into that rest? They
didn't because they didn't believe. And
hundreds of thousands of them died in
the wilderness and never entered into
the promised land.
So he says here in verses 3 to 7, it
remains for some to enter this rest.
Specifically in verses 6 and 7, notice
what he says.
Therefore, it remains for some to enter
it, and those who formally receive the
good news failed to enter because of
disobedience.
So he again so again he appoints a
certain day today saying through David
so long afterward
in the words already quoted today if you
hear his voice do not harden your
hearts. So he's applying Psalm 95:11 to
us.
He isn't simply giving us a history
lesson about the children of Israel.
He's giving us an exhortation for today.
Don't disobey in the wilderness of life
like they did.
Don't fail to believe the gospel.
Then in verses 8 to10, he's going to
begin to explain for us what the rest
is.
He says, "If Joshua had given them rest,
God would not have spoken of another
day." Later on,
another day.
Another day. One more time.
Another day.
We can debate what this another day is,
but this is being said in contrast to
the seventh day which is mentioned back
in verse 4.
Joshua and the Israelites were observing
the seventh day memorial. He mentions
the seven day 7th day memorial back in
verse four and contrast it here.
Adventists will say right because they
weren't believing that was the problem.
But the author tells us God wouldn't
have through the psalmist spoken of
another day if there wasn't one.
There's now another day. Now, many
commentators will associate this another
day with today. That's been mentioned
throughout chapters 3 and 4. And that's
absolutely correct. Today is the day of
of salvation. Today is the day to enter
the rest of God. Today, if you hear his
voice, do not harden your hearts. And so
on.
The rest he's talking about is not the
land of Canaan. The reader might be
tempted to think, "So, the children of
Israel uh didn't believe God in the
wilderness and died. Therefore, they
didn't enter into the rest of the land
of Canaan," which that is true. And he
tells us that the the land of Canaan is
a picture of the ultimate rest. But it's
not the ultimate rest, which he explains
to us in the next verses when he says
verse 8, "If Joshua had given them rest,
God would not have spoken of another day
later on." He's saying if Joshua, who
brought the children of Israel into the
promised land 40 years later, was giving
them the ultimate rest, God wouldn't
still be speaking about another rest
that's still to come.
Did you catch that?
If Joshua, who brought the children of
Israel into the promised land 40 years
later, was giving them the ultimate
rest, God wouldn't still be speaking
about another day, another rest that
still is to come.
Then in verse 9,
so there remains a Sabbath rest for the
people of God. The word Sabbath here is
Sabatismos, which includes more than
just a rest. Adventists love this. It
literally means a Sabbath rest or
Sabbathkeeping. And that is correct.
There remains a Sabbathkeeping for the
people of God.
Now to this point the author has
referred to rest or the rest of God
as the Greek word catapos
but now he uses sabatismos. And so
grammatically they are not identical.
And Adventist by the way if you want to
appeal to this here you need to be
consistent and also appeal this across
the board. And when Jesus said I am lord
of the Sabbath that is not cury heimera.
Two totally different words. Be
consistent folks.
So, not only does a rest remain, as we
will see, the true eternal rest one can
enter into by faith in Christ, but a
Sabbath rest as well.
So, not only is there a rest of God
entering into by entering, which we
enter into by entering into Christ, but
another day as well, a new memorial.
There's an eternal rest we have yet to
enter, but there's also another day as
well that memorializes this eternal
rest.
Now, Adventists love to cite verse four,
which talks about the original creation,
and then jump to here and say, "See, a
Sabbatismos, a Sabbath rest, it remains,
and it's the seventh day Sabbath because
he mentioned it in verse four." No.
Think again, my friend. Think again.
You're missing the meat of what the
author is dishing out. No pun intended.
There's an order of something bigger
being presented here. The previous rest
of God in both the original creation and
redemption from Egypt had three elements
that parallel one another. Okay?
Mighty acts of God working. That's one.
Two, God's completion of this work where
he ceases or rests from the that
miraculous work and switches to the work
of upholding what he's done. And three,
both of the previous rests of God have a
memorial day attached to them as a sign
and pledge of the rest of God.
So there's three things that that were
taking place in creation.
A mighty work of God,
a completion of that work followed by a
rest.
That's what's been getting laid out and
contrasted or explained for us here in
Hebrews 3 and 4.
And then we have presented to us that an
eternal rest does still exist for us
today for the people of God. But there
also exists a sabatismos for the current
people of God. But it's another day.
Verse 10 then becomes pivotal.
Pivotal.
He that has entered into his rest has
also ceased from his works as God did
from his. So the millionoll question,
who is the he that is mentioned?
Who's the he that is mentioned?
A common interpretation of this is that
it is talking about believers in general
entering God's rest.
Used to hold to this myself. And I do
believe that we do enter into the true
well, I'm going to get to that.
But grammatically, the issue with that
interpretation is that the he is
singular. It's a singular personal in
the Greek. That matters.
It means it's referring to a specific
individual in reference.
It's not a generic he to refer to like
mankind.
The NASB's rendering on this is actually
spoton. Instead of he, it reads, for the
one who has entered his rest has himself
also rested from his works as God did
from his.
So a single individual is being talked
about who entered his own rest just as
God rested from his works and entered
his. Catch this folks, this is crucial.
The he that enters his rest must be
doing so in a parallel way to God in
creation.
God finished his works, saw that they
were good, and so he ceased and rested
the seventh day. If we apply this to
this text to believers,
it is necessary that we ask what works
do believers cease from that parallel
God ceasing his at creation.
Well, we would say it's oftentimes
people will say it's well, it's us
resting from our works.
Well, we can't compare our works to
God's works. Our attempts at working for
salvation do resting from from those
works at of trying to work for
salvation. Those works do not compare to
God's works in creation.
The Bible describes the works that we
rest from when we're in Christ as dead
works.
So clearly we don't take delight in and
enjoy our previous works as God did in
being pleased with his work of creation
which is what is meant by God resting.
He was taking delight in his
accomplishment. He wasn't tired.
So we don't rest from our works of sin
and then look over the previous th those
previous works with delight. So it isn't
a consistent parallel.
The he in verse 10 has to be someone who
did a work comparable to God's work in
creation.
A mighty act of one work that was two
completed and followed by three a rest.
A work that is good that he can take
delight in.
Then when those works are finished, he
ceases from his works just as God did in
creation and enters his rest just as God
did in creation.
It's talking about Jesus, folks. It's
talking about Jesus. Jesus did a mighty
work of redeeming the creation. He
completed that work successfully. Upon
doing so, entered into his mediatorial
rest for his people.
The text fits like a glove when applied
to Christ rather than believers.
Because then we enter into the true
Sabbath rest by being in Christ.
He's the doorway. I I mean there's just
so many parallels there between the his
curtain the the the his flesh being the
curtain and the doorway and being the
door. It just sorry I don't want to get
sidetracked.
But the only thing left to establish is
when Christ entered his rest after his
works of redemption were finished.
God and creation did so on the seventh
day.
Christ in redemption entered the first
day with his resurrection from the dead
which demonstrated the work of
redemption was complete, finished,
accomplished.
1 Corinthians 15 where we previously
were in verses 1-4 it clearly states
that the resurrection was a part of
Christ's gospel work remember Paul said
if Christ was not raised from the dead
then our faith is useless so death on
the cross as a sacrifice was not enough
if he wasn't raised the work was still
going on the resurrection is the
transition point where Jesus went from
his humiliation meaning he incarnated as
a man humbled himself under the law
Galatians 4:4 etc
from his humiliation to his exaltation,
the period from his resurrection through
to the second coming. So, he humiliated
all the way down from heaven to the
depths of the grave.
But then all of that reverses with his
resurrection where he's highly exalted
as savior, king of kings, lord of lords,
and returns back to his rightful status.
Now,
some will argue that the he in verse 10
doesn't specify Christ. He isn't
referenced by name. Well, again, like I
mentioned at the beginning, we have to
remember that Hebrews 4 is a
continuation from chapter 3. In Hebrews
3, specifically verses 6 and 14, Jesus
is mentioned by name.
And it's all about being in Christ.
That's how you enter into the true
esqueological rest. By believing the
gospel, you end up entering into Christ.
But the whole focus here is about being
in Christ. So Christ is mentioned there
in chapter 3. He's the whole focal point
of the whole book of Hebrews. And these
two chapters are no exception.
It is Christ because
get the verses back here. It's Christ
because what's being described is a
perfect parallel to the three parallels
mentioned earlier. Again, a mighty act
of God working, completion of this work
followed by resting, which is more akin
to enjoying or appreciating reaping the
fruits of the labor. And that is exactly
what Jesus did for us. His mighty act of
working for our redemption, he completed
it perfectly, entered his mediatorial
rest, seated in heaven where he rules
and reigns, and is reaping the fruit of
his labors as a conquering uh as a
conqueror making all things new.
Revelation 20 21:5. Again, this is how
Jesus can be the true fulfillment of the
Sabbath. Yet a sabatismos, a Sabbath
rest, can remain. But it's another day,
a new memorial, the day when Jesus
accomplished redemption and entered his
rest, the first day.
So to hopefully make all this a little
bit easier.
Let's summarize.
That should be 4 1- 11, not 1- 10. But I
guess what we're talking about here is
the 10 verses.
We have another rest. The rest that
remains. That is the gospel rest. You
enter into that by believing God and
believing his gospel.
It also typifies
the eternal state that we await to enter
into. That's where the seventh day, I'm
going to talk about this a little bit
later, so maybe I'm getting ahead of
myself, but nevertheless, that's why the
indefinite period is also a a important
aspect of the seventh day because Jesus
is now in this indefinite period where
he is going to forever Adventists
mediate on behalf of his people in that
restful state.
But we have another rest, the gospel
that or the rest that remains, which is
the gospel rest. two, not only do we
have another rest, the gospel rest in
Christ, but another day, too.
Verse eight.
Number three, not only does a general
rest of God remain, but a Sabbath rest
specifically,
Sabatismos.
The parallels verify, number four, the
par the parallels verify that not only
is there a work followed by a rest of
God, but that there is a memorial day
that points to that rest and is a sign
of it.
Number five, in the gospel rest, Christ
is the one who performs then ceases from
his works just as God did from his in
creation. We then enter that by entering
into Christ by faith.
Number six, in creation, God worked.
God's works were finished on the seventh
day, but in redemption, Christ's works
are finished the morning of the first
day.
And seven, being faithful to the
parallels of the passage, the sabotismos
in verse 9 has to have reference to the
first day. It's uh being the day that
Christ has rested or ceased from his
works. Not only that, but it cannot be
the seventh day because the phrase
another day is used in contrast to the
seventh day.
This is why the Christian church
worships every seven days from that
memorial and why people point to the
resurrection as the basis for it.
They may not understand all the details
around it like we just walked through,
but it's not just arbitrarily because
Jesus resurrected.
That resurrection represented something
significant.
New creation inaugurated brought with it
a new memorial, a cataclysmic shift in
all of creation.
Adventists will just say it's only
because the resurrection and Christians
have no basis from that. Yet they don't
see all these other details which are
what laid the foundation for that
summary statement.
By his redemption, Jesus made a new
creation. 2 Corinthians 5:1 17-9, Romans
8:1 19-2.
And entered his rest. Hebrews 4:10. He
again gave us the pledge of the first
day which holds out the promise of our
consummation state as we labor for
Christ's kingdom and seek to build uh or
seek to subdue all things which Hebrews
2 5-8 explains actually.
And since we're sinners, this would also
be an impossible request. So Christ not
only enters his own creation or or
sorry. So Christ not only enters um his
rest as God, but as our representative
second Adam, he labors to subdue all
things to himself on our behalf. Hebrews
1:13 and 28-18.
Just like the first Adam was commanded
to subdue the earth in Genesis and
failed, the second Adam, Jesus, did that
perfectly.
We're still called to do this, by the
way, by taking the gospel to all tribes,
tongues, peoples, and nations, letting
them know the good news that Jesus has
conquered death. You can have your sins
forgiven in him, and rule and reign with
him as a king. But before we can subdue
the world to Christ, we have to first
rest in his finished work of redemption.
The ultimate Sabbath rest one enters
enters into by faith is the gospel rest
that believers are promised by being in
Christ. The day when our bodies will no
longer ache, wear down, etc.
We will be in an eternal Sabbath rest
enjoying God forever in total
perfection. Until then, a sabatismos, a
Sabbath rest does remain where we get a
glimpse and foretaste of this eternal
Sabbath by gathering with the saints
everywhere to every week to worship the
King of Kings and the Lord of Lords. Our
bodies still need a weekly rest right
now until they're glorified, which will
take place when we enter into the true
final eternal Sabbath rest that Jesus
has already entered into before us.
Even the seventh day in Genesis having
no evening and morning like I mentioned
an indefinite period of time was
typological of this eternal rest that
awaits us. Jesus has already entered
into this rest ahead of us. He's already
in the eternal state that we await. Just
like the seventh day in creation was an
indefinite amount of time. So is the
rest in the gospel that Jesus has
already entered into and we will enter
by being in him one day.
It's all about Jesus and the gospel.
Folks, that's what Sunday is about. It's
about Jesus and the gospel. The good
news that Jesus has accomplished
redemption.
This first day memorial is is nothing
like the Adventist church paints the
seventh day Sabbath.
It's just it's just nothing like what
they paint it. It is it is a foretaste
of the eternal Sabbath rest that we will
acquire on the other side.
It's a small glimpse into that. I love
Sunday. It's my favorite day of the
week.
The substance is not the day, folks.
It's Jesus. The day is the memorial. The
remains the same. It's always been about
Jesus in the gospel.
But Adventists, for those who have ears
to hear, let them hear. And even if
you're not an Adventist,
you will fail to enter the true Sabbath
rest if you harden your heart and do not
believe the pure unadulterated gospel.
That's the call
whether you're an Adventist or not.
That's the warning the author gives
before laying all this out. Don't be
like Israel who failed to enter in.
Believe the pure gospel, my friends.
Cling to it. The Adventist Church
doesn't have it. You can't possibly
enter in by the Adventist message when
the Adventist message is not the gospel.
Adventists, if you hear these words, he
who has ears to hear, let him hear.
Believe the true gospel.
Do not fail to enter in like they did.
Folks, if you think that because you go
to church on Saturday, you've entered
in, you are lost. I'm sorry, but you are
lost.
You're lost. You're not in. You don't
understand what it's actually about.
You can keep laboring on that seventh
day Sabbath. Yes, laboring.
Doing your darnest,
thinking it's going to seal you.
You're lost.
Believe the pure gospel.
That's what Israel did not believe and
their hearts were hardened to it. Soften
your heart to the gospel message.
Now, the Adventist church thinks they're
clever by claiming Jesus rested in the
tomb on the seventh day Sabbath,
signifying the importance of it. But
what they failed to realize is that
Jesus was working in the tomb, not
resting.
He was accomplishing the redemption of
his people, paying the penalty for their
sins. His death was not sufficient in
and of itself. Like I said earlier, say
it. Say it again.
Paul says in 1 Corinthians 15 that if
Christ was not resurrected, our faith is
in vain and we're still in our sins.
Jesus was working in the tomb and works
of necessity and mercy were permitted on
the Sabbath, which is exactly what Jesus
um was doing was works of mercy, which
means Jesus wasn't breaking the Sabbath
by his work either. He rested upon
resurrecting because the work was then
accomplished.
Now he sits on his throne reaping the
fruit of his labors as our eternal
mediator and bridge to God while all of
his enemies are being made a foottool.
In fact, now that Jesus has come, it's
an insult to his grace to continue to
celebrate a seventh day Sabbath. Yep, I
said it.
It's like saying he has not come. You're
celebrating the type and shadow as if
the substance hasn't come and isn't
here. Same thing as like in the early
church how it was like with
circumcision. You're basically saying
Christ is that was the type and shadow
of the substance.
Se memorializing the seventh day is like
memorializing that the incarnation
hadn't happened, that creation still
hasn't been redeemed, that the Messiah
hasn't come and accomplished redemption.
The seventh day typified the work of
Christ to come. But because the SD
church is just so hung up on a 24-hour
rotation around the sun, it is just
they can't see it. They can't see it.
Just some other overview proofs of the
first day, the day after the Sabbath
being important and typological in
scripture of Jesus's redeeming work.
The new creation was anticipated by the
Jubilee year, which was the year after
the 7th 7. Christ declared himself to be
a fulfillment of the Jubilee in Luke uh
4:19.
Every Sunday is the day after the
seventh. It's a miniature jubilee, if
you will, a foretaste of heaven on earth
while we gather and celebrate what
Christ has accomplished. There's all
sorts of parallels like this
because it was going somewhere. The
Sabbath was pointing to something bigger
and greater than this idea that days are
divine and eternally exist. And
uh also Psalm 118, and we could go deep
on this one as well.
This new creation is recognized to be a
a a new day which the Lord has made.
Psalm 118:24,
namely the resurrection day when when
Christ entered again his mediatorial
rest. This resurrection day fulfills
actually in the new the new creation the
function that the old day that was made
by God had. It's set apart as his day,
the Lord's day. Revelation 11:0 despite
all the scoffers. This is why like we
looked at Hebrews 4:8 indicating that
when Psalm 95 is referring to another
day, namely the resurrection day, it
signifies that there remains therefore a
Sabbath rest for the people of God. We
could go really deep on that one. That's
a very common one that a lot of exedites
have done work on. I mean, then you have
your just your standard proof text
defenses people use to show worship,
Eucharist, etc. taking place on the
first day. Acts 20:7, 1 Corinthians
16:1, etc.
Again, I'm just browsing over these here
because again, we could be here all
night on this topic.
But remember, we have no biblical
support at all for this supposedly. No,
no biblical support.
No biblical support.
It's all just tradition and no, no
biblical support.
We just did a systematic rundown on the
topics of creation, rest, and
redemption. The three things the Sabbath
is rooted in, showing there's a lot more
going on than simply going to church on
Saturday, of which we could keep going,
like I said, but we're only, you know,
we're the only ones who don't have
biblical warrant for our practices. Got
it. Okay.
If the Adventist church supposedly has
biblical support that Satan held a
diabolical board meeting in outer space
to plot how to attack Adventists for
going to church on Saturday.
Okay,
don't give me that, Mark. Don't give me
that. You're free to disagree,
but it is a bald-faced lie to say that
this is a product of Sylvester when
history and scripture testify otherwise.
The problem isn't scripture, sir. The
problem is your guys' bad hermeneutic
and standard that thinks if something
isn't verbatim stated, then it isn't in
the Bible.
I could go on and on and on. What you
guys should really say is, I disagree
with their interpretation.
This issue really rests on this biblical
idea that the Bible is to be under or or
this interpretive issue of the idea that
the Bible is to be understood wholly on
the basis of single proof texts. A
1500's edition that wasn't for the
purpose of building entire systems of
theology off of
the pro the purpose of of these things.
Mark, the Sabatismos that remains is in
contrast to the seventh day because it's
talking about another day. And we're
told if there hadn't been another day,
David wouldn't have mentioned one.
It's right there.
You just have to read the text together
and not isolate out verses four and
nine.
It's right there, sir.
another day
in contrast to the old day.
I challenge anyone on the basis of the
grammar to refute that exesus. Not
because I said it. I'm simply sharing
what I've gathered through my own deep
study on the topic.
Grammatically, this buries the SDA Old
Creation Memorial.
Obviously, there are going to be those
who aren't SDA that also disagree.
That's fine. But I care about what the
author's intended meaning is, not what I
want the author to be saying. I care
about the truth. I care about the facts.
And this once it clicks, folks, it it is
just
I I've had SDAs ask me, "If we could
convince you of the Seventh Day Sabbath,
would you would you become an
Adventist?" And I tell him, well, the
the first hurdle that you'd have to get
over, which is an impossible one for you
to get over, is for me to no longer see
this in scripture.
It's like the same thing with infant
baptism. Um, well, we don't want to go
off on that, but no, you you you can't
because once this clicks, it it's just
it
it's such a beautiful doctrine when you
remove all of this 19th century pseudo
conspiracy nonsense. the Adventist
church has added to this and tried to
latch on to.
But folks, I refuse to concede any
doctrine to the SDA church. I don't care
what it is.
I will concede zero scripture to them. I
will not concede the law. I won't
concede the Sabbath. I won't concede any
of it to them because they are a leech
system that came up in the 19th century
who's trying to ride the coattails of
others and then capitalize on something
that a good majority of people just
don't have a strong theology around. So,
they're able to build up these wild
narratives and crazy conspiracy theories
and take something that is good,
righteous, and just and taint it by
completely missing what it is and
creating their own tradition.
the the the the people who say I have no
tradition, they are slaves to tradition.
That is the sign you are a slave to
tradition because everyone has
tradition. It's just a matter of how you
view that tradition and how you treat
that tradition. But now to top all this
off,
let's look at a number of individuals
down through history who've understood
this solely for the purpose of silencing
the silly myth that the first day
corporate worship is a product of Pope
Sylvester or Constantine. Insert
whatever myth you want. Because if you
think I came up with all this, you think
way too highly of me.
I want to look at Athanasius, Augustine,
Yius, who the White House or White
House, who the white estate mentions in
the great controversy appendix, by the
way, and some Protestant reformers who
continue digging into this subject where
those that came before them left off.
This is so you can see this isn't
answering Adventism's private
interpretation. I stand on the shoulders
of giants. And there's a lot more than
this. This is simply a sampling. This
will also silence the myth that the
church fathers and everyone before the
Adventists didn't appeal to scripture
for the basis of this belief. They love
this narrative that they're the real
Bible believers.
Everyone else just follows man-made
traditions. Okay. Okay. So, first up,
we're actually going to look at Ignatius
because we're going to go in the order
of
year.
So, first up, Ignatius of Ania, 2
century. We read a portion of this
earlier, but let's see him expound.
Notice what he says.
Be not deceived with strange doctrines,
nor with old fables which are
unprofitable.
For if we shall live according to the
Jewish law, we acknowledge that we have
not received grace.
So, like I was saying earlier, clinging
to the old order is a rejection of the
substance that has come.
This is typically where the stubborn SDA
will say, "See, they just hated the
Jews." And other character attacks. But
no, this isn't why he said this. He's
rightly recognizing what the Sabbath was
a memorial of and a sign of that we're
in the substance. Now he continues,
"If therefore those who were brought up
in the ancient order of things, meaning
the Jews, have come to the possession of
a new hope, no longer observing the
Sabbath, but living in the observance of
the Lord's day, on which also our life
has sprung up again by him and by his
death. Let every friend of Christ keep
the Lord's day as a festival, the
resurrection day, the queen and chief of
all the days of the week."
It is absurd to speak of Jesus Christ
with the tongue and to cherish in the
mind a Judaism which has now come to an
end. For where there is Christianity,
there cannot be Judaism. Close quote.
Ignatius of Antioch Epistle to
Magnesians chapter 9. Ah, but remember
none of the early church viewed the
first day as any different than any
other day. Right?
He calls it the queen and chief of the
weekdays
because it's the day in which he in
which we ourselves those who are in
Christ were raised with him talking
about Christ.
We remember that and celebrated every
Sunday. That's what the old memorial was
a shadow of. Ignatius rooted the Lord's
day in the new creation. The old
creation was gone because Christ had
accomplished the redemption of it.
And it's on the and it's on the day that
it was completed that we memorialize
that fact followed by repeating that
celebration every seven days from the
new memorial following the same pattern.
Next up, a fellow we looked at earlier,
origin writing in the 3rd century. What
does he say?
Quote, "Hence, it is not possible that
the day of rest after the Sabbath should
have come into existence from the
seventh day of our God. On the contrary,
it is our savior who after the pattern
of his own rest," Hebrews 4,
caused us to be made in the likeness of
his death and hence also of his
resurrection. Close quote. Origin of
Alexandria, that's his commentary on
John 2:28,
3rd century.
same thing. He calls the day after the
Sabbath a rest day and appeals to it as
being authoritative
or or rather authorized as such by
Christ himself by the way by way of the
apostles
after the pattern of God's rest in
creation also rested.
It was on this day that we by being in
Christ were buried and raised with him.
They weren't just willy-nilly pulling
this stuff out of thin air, folks. The
Adventist Church likes to poo poo on
history and tradition as if it's some
like ethereal nebulous thing where
people one day just up and stated
something to be so and everyone ran with
it. No, these men were grappling with
the biblical text just like theologians
today are. And the church has been
continually continually building on
their theology. They'll want to appeal
oftent times to say, you know, the the a
restoration is is very similar to the
reformation because technically
Adventism is a restorationist group.
They think they're restoring something
and they don't understand. No, the
arguments going on in the reformation
were whether or not the tradition can be
reformed or not or if it's infallible.
We're not saying they're infallible, but
as you're going to see, people are
coming up here who I'm going to show
you, who continued building on what the
church fathers rightly understood about
scripture.
They were appealing to biblical texts.
It wasn't just some willy-nilly thing
that they were just coming up with. Now
to the 4th century,
Athanasius the Great, Athanasius of
Alexandria,
this is from his on Sabbath and on
circumcision three, fourth century.
He says, "The Sabbath was the end of the
first creation. The Lord's day was the
beginning of the second
in which he renewed and restored the old
in the same way as he prescribed that
they should formally observe the Sabbath
as a memorial of the end of the first
things. So we honor the Lord's day as
the as being the memorial of the new
creation."
Close quote.
St. Athanasius is explaining the same
thing we just walked through new
creation. That's why I said early on
that's the key. This is never brought up
in Adventist discussions. I'm telling
you folks, their system cannot account
for new creation being a present
reality. Once that is established, it is
over. It's over
because then you have they agree that
the Sabbath is rooted in creation.
Right? So, do we have two creations or
one creation? And if we have a new
creation, now we need to look at some of
these other things like we looked at
tonight.
The seventh day Sabbath was the memorial
of the old creation that fell and needed
redeemed. The Lord's day, the first day,
the day after the Sabbath, is the
memorial of the new. It's what the old
pointed to because the substance is
Jesus.
It pointed to him and the great work he
would accomplish. That's what we're
celebrating on the first day, not the
sun.
not worshiping creation, all these silly
straw men that SDA apologists and
leadership try and throw out. No, we
worship the one who redeemed the
creation and celebrate what he has done.
It's about Jesus for us, not a day. The
day is the memorial, not the substance.
I'm going to keep saying that. We're
going to say that for years to come on
this channel. I hope it clicks at some
point for for a person who it dawns on
them. Wow. Wow. Ah, I see what you're
saying now. Yeah, it's not about a day.
It's about the person.
The day is a memorial.
Again, fourth century. Some of the white
estate mentions in the appendix of the
great controversy actually because they
think it helps him out. Yius,
church historian extraordinaire.
Notice what he says. This is actually
back in 4th century. This is his
commentary on on Psalm 92, which this is
a whole interesting thing that we could
get into as well, which again would be
it its own thing, but he says, quote,
"The word talking about Christ by the
new covenant translated and transferred
the feast of the Sabbath to the morning
light and gave us the image of the true
rest, the day of salvation." Today is
the day of salvation.
They're appealing to Hebrews here. The
Lord's day, the first of the light, on
which the Savior of the world after all
his labors among men obtained the
victory over death and passed the
portals of heaven, having achieved a
work superior to the six days creation
of this day and received the divine
Sabbath and blessed rest when the Father
said to him, "Sit at my right hand until
I make all your enemies a foottool."
On that day, which is the first of light
and of the true sun, we also assemble
after an interval of six days and
celebrate holy and spiritual Sabbaths.
Close quote.
Yet again, just like we saw in Hebrews,
Yibius also recognized this. Christ did
a work superior to that of God in
creation and accomplished it on the
first day. He ceased from the work of
redemption by sitting on his throne.
This is something that the Levitical
ironic priest never did
because the work of dealing with sin was
never finished.
But Christ did accomplish the work and
entered his mediatorial rest for his
people. Now he's ruling and reigning and
subduing all of his enemies by subduing
the earth which he will successfully
accomplish.
It's what Adam failed to do.
The church celebrates this and worships
the the one on the throne every seven
days from the new memorial. Don't don't
let these groups like SDAs theologically
bully you into thinking that you're they
have some monopoly on scripture and the
law or any of that. They don't. They
wrongfully define things in this case
what it means to keep the Sabbath by
inserting their short-sighted narrow
19th century tradition upon the text and
then tell everyone else they're wrong.
Nope. Not going to happen. At least not
on answering Adventism. Like I said, I
refuse to concede any scripture to them,
any part of God's word. Like Paul told
Timothy, all scriptures God God
breathed. All scripture.
It's also God breathed. Adventists, not
God thought inspired, God breathed.
And Paul says it's all profitable for
teaching, reprove, correction, etc. So,
no, I refuse to concede the Sabbath to
them as if Christians haven't from the
very beginning rightfully understood
what the scriptures are saying.
The new creation obliterates their old
memorial idol.
Now into the fifth century,
as many are aware, one of my favorite
theologians,
Augustine, Augustine, for those that are
sticklers,
notice what he says in his book, City of
God.
City of God, book 22, chapter 30.
quote after this period meaning this
present age
God shall rest as on the seventh day
when he shall give us who shall be the
seventh day rest in himself so halt
really quick what he means by this is
that we live in a in the period of the
seventh day because it wasn't capped off
with evening and morning it was an
indefinite ceasing that God did from
creating we live in that period of time
so he's just saying after this present
age God will give us believers rest in
himself
referring to the eternal rest to come in
the next age, the next life. Like I was
saying earlier, he continues,
"But there is not now space to treat of
these ages. Suffice it to say that the
seventh shall be our Sabbath, which
shall be brought to a close not by an
evening, but by the Lord's day, as an
eighth and eternal day, consecrating by
the resurrection of Christ, and
prefiguring the eternal repose not only
of the spirit, but also of the body.
There we shall rest and see this eternal
esqueological rest we're going to see
and love. Love and praise. This is what
shall be in the end without end. For
what other end do we propose to
ourselves than to attain to the kingdom
of which there is no end?
Close quote.
So Augustine rightly points out the
other components we mentioned from
Hebrews that even the new creation
memorial has an element of pointing
forward to the age to come.
to our eternal rest, not just for our
souls now, but even of our physical
bodies, the day in which our physical
bodies will be glorified.
The new memorial and the old memorial
prefigure this eternal rest we long for.
They point, they both pointed to that
which is ultimately found in Jesus
Christ,
which again, the substance of that is
Jesus. We enter into the heavenly
promised land by being in him.
Now for a couple of Protestant
reformers, we could have gone through
the medieval period and
I just want to show you since the
Adventist church claims to be heirs of
the Protestant Reformation.
So simply to show this chain of thought
all the way up to the Reformation in
present day, the reformers were simply
seeking to build upon the studies of
those who came before them.
Contrary to the straw man that is often
pinned on many of them that they were
just coming up with this like novel
doctrine. No. Read their writings. Read
their writings. You're you're the
argument back then was well you're
interpreting them wrong. Not that you're
not appealing to the church universal to
show that this is in line with what's
being said. But notice what they
articulate. This is just classical
Protestant thought.
Hinrich Wolf,
sometimes referred to historically as
Wolfius.
He was a professor of Hebrew in Zurich,
which is now Switzerland. It was the
Canton regions during the heart of the
Swiss Reformation. It wasn't Switzerland
yet, but during the Reformation in
Zurich,
professor of Hebrew, what does he say on
this specific topic?
Christ did appoint the new Sabbath when
our last enemy death being overcome. He
made an end of the labors of our
redemption which in his humanity were to
be born. So see he even understood quote
close quote here real quick.
There is a parallel there to us resting
from our works and entering in by
Christ.
There is a a level of that. But
specifically verse 10 that we were
looking at earlier, the he there I would
argue is talking about Christ. But
that's what Wolfus mentions here. He
says, "He made an end of the labors of
our redemption, which in his humanity
were to be born. And the next day, with
the new man restored, he brought out of
the grave a new time,
the time of our creation, and of the new
covenant, and did prepare an everlasting
Sabbath into the which himself then
entered
for us also at the time appointed by
virtue of his resurrection to be entered
into.
Therefore, as in the time of the
creation,
that day which was first of the creation
finished was made holy for the worship
of God. So now in the time of
redemption, that day which is first
after the finishing of it is to be
accounted holy of us. Close quote.
Again,
the whole concept is rooted in the new
creation.
If the new creation is underway, which
scripture tells us it is,
it's just it isn't here in its fullness
yet, then the old creation memorial is
gone along with the old creation.
Just like circumcision,
these things were types and shadows.
Jesus is the substance.
We aren't living in the type and shadow
anymore.
Christ's resurrection changed
everything. It changed the entire world.
We're now in the time of redemption
truly realized.
And Wolfius points out how Christ
entered into the eternal esqueological
Sabbath that we await to enter into
eternity itself.
And we have access to that by entering
into Christ by faith. Until then, we
celebrate the accomplishment of the of
Christ's mighty works on the Lord's day
until he returns and we acquire acquire
the fullness of that promise.
This is why the battlecry of the
reformers was the ancient church is on
our side
because they continued building upon
where the fathers left off. You can't
expect human beings to in their lifetime
just have nailed down every single
facet, jot and tit perfectly from day
one. That's just not the way it works.
God has been leading and guiding the
church. Can the church make errors at
certain points? Of course, we're
fallible. I know that there's some
traditions out there that would argue
with that. That's fine. Not the purpose
of of tonight. But
this idea of completely denuting from
history, they were all deceived. They
were all pagans. That's a forgery. Like,
no, that's not the way it works. We
continue building upon where we were,
and we continue to reform ourselves in
accordance with scripture. And if
something gets out of whack, we correct
it with the with the scriptures.
Lastly,
let's look at uh Giralamo Zanki. It's my
attempt, I guess, at an Italian accent.
Zanki, lesser known of the reformers. He
was an Italian reformer. So, not in the
Swiss regions with Calvin and Basa, not
in Germany with Luther and
Kenets, but Italy. He was friends with
uh Peter Martyr Vermilier, another
Italian reformer. I've mentioned him a
little bit on the channel before, but
notice what he says here. Little bit of
a long quote. He says, quote, "If for
the memory of our redemption, one day in
the week is to be celebrated, meaning a
memorial, and our redemption was
perfected on the day that followed the
Jews Sabbath, which is called the
Lord's. Then upon just consideration was
the sanctification of the Sabbath
removed unto the Lord's day. Upon that
day the church should meet for public
worship of God is set down by the
tradition of the apostles.
And that is out of controversy among all
the learned.
Out of controversy among all the
learned.
Meaning there's not a bunch of
conspiracies around this folks.
For although we have no express
commandment from the apostles in plain
words for keeping holy of the Lord's
day, yet we doubt but not or or sorry
yet we doubt not but that it is their
tradition because St. John makes mention
of it in Revelation 1:10. Anyway does he
call it the Lord's day even because of
that custom that was already received
among the Christians because that our
Lord Jesus by rising again upon that day
did finish our salvation. For he rose
again for our justification, as the
apostle says. Romans 4:25,
and did as it were, make a new world
when he renewed all things. Close quote.
What does he appeal to? The apostles.
It was the apostolic tradition laid out
by them with the understanding being
that the first day was the new memorial
of the new creation that Jesus
inaugurated by resurrecting and
redeeming the creation.
None of these people had any issue
strugg or or struggle with understanding
the Sabbath. Folks, this myth from the
SDA church that they have the Sabbath
light and they're taking it to the world
and reviving some long-lost relic is
just pure fiction. Sorry, but it's it's
fiction.
They'll often say people reject the
Sabbath because they haven't had the
Adventist light on it presented to them.
When in reality, the Adventist light is
simply old school Judaizing reinjected
and revived. Like most of SDA theology,
it's just a resurrection of a variety of
heresies.
Small clip here from Mark Finley before
we close things out, just to to end
things off.
3 verse 9.
If the devil hates Christ and if Christ
is the creator and if the devil can
undermine creation by undermining the
Sabbath of creation, he can discredit
Jesus. So Ephesians 3:9 to make all
people see what is the fellowship of the
mystery which from the beginning of the
ages has been hidden in God. Now what's
the next phrase? Let's read the next
phrase together. You ready, church?
Let's read it together. who created all
things through Jesus Christ. So since
Jesus is the active agent in creation,
the Sabbath, don't miss this, is a
monument or memorial to Jesus and into
his creative power. Satan hates Jesus.
He sees Jesus as a rival. His supreme
desire is to cast Jesus off his throne
and rule the universe. So by attacking
the Sabbath, Satan attacks Jesus. The
evil one wants to destroy the Sabbath
because he wants to destroy Christ. This
is precisely why God sends an eternal
last day message to all humanity calling
them back to Sabbath worship.
Did you catch that?
A number of things
in light of everything we just looked at
regarding the first day, where the
Christian church is getting this, why it
was a universal practice, etc.,
Mark claims that going to church on
Sunday is about dethroning Jesus and not
worshiping him as creator.
really really
Mark the entire reason we worship on
Sunday is because it's a memorial of the
new creation the day that Jesus
accomplished the redemption the creator
the day he accomplished the redemption
of his people and redeemed the fallen
creation
celebrating that he's made us new
creatures in Christ freeing us from our
slavery to sin that we've been
reconciled to God
the resurrection represented all of this
sir that's That's why Christians are
there.
That's who we're worshiping and what
we're celebrating. The ones worshiping
creation are the ones worshiping a day
and not a person.
The ones that can't differentiate
between the memorial itself, which can
and has changed, and the substance that
the memorial points to.
Satan did not set up Sunday to attack
Jesus.
Now you can see folks why in light of
the facts, it's hard to take this
seriously.
This is just Ellen White being told in a
dramatic fashion
with a few Bible verses sprinkled in.
He said, "This is exactly why a last day
movement was raised up to call people
back to Sabbath worship."
Sir, the irony of this statement is that
the Adventist message is the lie of
Satan. It is the trap. It is a part of
the great apostasy.
It is a part of the mass of teachings
that are leading people astray after a
false Christ and a false gospel using a
false prophet and a false church to do
it.
Also, he called their message an eternal
last day message.
It's like the constant conundrum. How
can the message be eternal but relegated
to the last days?
It's like present truth. Is it still
present truth if it's 170 years later?
But this is just further proof, folks,
that what the SDA church calls the
gospel is not.
They can use all the slick words
smithing and creative writing. It's not
going to work.
What Mark is saying is that the seventh
day Sabbath is a part of the gospel.
It's part of what one must believe to be
reconciled to God and have peace with
him. Mark, that is not the gospel.
And your movement was not raised up by
God. The pioneers of the Adventist
church like JN Andrews that we read from
earlier was an aryan heretic. All the
pioneers were.
That fact alone proves that God was not
behind any of this.
So in closing, the Adventist Church
needs to stop slandering the body of
Christ, claiming we believe things that
we don't, like worshiping the sun, that
we worship on the first day because the
pope or Constantine or the council of
Leadyia, etc.
But the truth is that's the only defense
they have, folks. And it doesn't work on
those of us who have studied this topic
in depth.
So if you are an Adventist and you
continue pariting these lies, myths,
halftruth truths, you are bearing false
witness, the SDA church has lied to you.
They continue to parrot these same lies
from JN Andrews, James White, etc.
And it's it's lies. It's not true.
But one final thing that she mentioned
there that I want to end on or Mark
mentioned there, sorry. You know, he was
saying it was his imagination earlier,
but it was actually Ellen's imagination.
So, I'm still crossing wires.
The call of Hebrews 4 Adventists is to
enter the Sabbath rest,
believing the gospel.
This is not the gospel.
If you are trusting and have some sort
of security in the fact that you go to
church on a certain day, you are lost.
Someone needs to tell you this. You're
lost.
You don't know the gospel if that's what
you think.
That has zero bearing on you being
reconciled to God.
And don't jump to, oh, so you don't
believe in sanctification and obed
of of of tropes. I've said I don't know
how many times. I'm not advocating that.
simply saying that your your doings do
not add to the work of Christ. The
gospel is good news. It's a message.
That's what it means. Gospel means good
news. It's about the good news that
Jesus has done and how you can be
reconciled. That's it. It's not all the
other stuff from the law. And as you
just saw tonight, I'm not one of these
the law was nailed to the cross types.
I'm not advocating that. So don't jump
to that in your mind and think that
that's what I'm advocating for. But if
you think that you've entered the
Sabbath because you go to church on
Saturday and therefore you're keeping
it, you are no different than the
wilderness wanderers.
And the solemn warning that's given is
if you do not enter in by faith
believing the pure unadulterated gospel,
you will perish in the wilderness of
life.
You will die without Christ.
You need to repent of this false gospel.
This church is leading you after a false
gospel.
You need to believe the true gospel. We
care about you.
We have fun in these these things to
make light of the of the heaviness and
the weight of this.
Come to know the truth.
Come to know the truth. We all had to
follow. I've talked with thousands of
former Adventists. We all had to follow
the same path of accepting that, you
know, maybe we were lied to about there
being a diabolical space council of
Satan in some back alley of the Milky
Way somewhere.
That maybe there's something else going
on here.
Believe the true gospel, friend. Believe
the true gospel. Christ died for
sinners.
You have nothing to bring to the table.
You Your best day
only provides the sin necessary for you
to need a savior.
On my best day, I'm not even close to
making the standard. And I don't wake up
every day and just think, "Ah, I just
want to live however I want." And I
probably actually have the the opposite
effect. I probably have a a too guilty
of a conscience sometimes to where I
forget the good news myself.
The gospel is for believers every day to
be reminded of who we are in Christ. Our
union with Christ.
That in Christ you can be seen as
righteous right now.
Not after some probationary period where
you then do your part to demonstrate.
No. Right now.
There is therefore now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus. The
law can't condemn you. That's what being
freed up from underneath the law is
about. It's not that the law has zero
purpose. I'm not in that camp either.
And I think people that say that are
wrong. It's not just a frenzy. It's not
just anarchy. It's that you're not under
the law covenantally. Israel was under
the law covenantally. It had
stipulations. Do this and you'll live.
Do that and you'll die. There's no
stipulations for grace or mercy. You
break it once, you're screwed. There's
no provision for forgiveness. That's
where the gospel comes in. Jesus kept
the law perfectly. That's how the
requirements can be s fulfilled. That's
how God can be the just and the
justifier. That Christ keeps the law
perfectly. And since sin is a legal
debt, those legal debts can be
transferred. So Jesus Christ took our
legal debt and then gives us his perfect
righteousness. Holy, not little spurts
over time based on your this whole
sanctification system the SDA church has
set up. That is again a twisting of the
historic teaching of what sanctification
is.
Please Adventists consider what was said
tonight. Examine the text. There's of
course going to be those ones that it
doesn't matter what I say. I'm not
talking to you. I'm talking to the
Adventist that's going to hear this
today, tomorrow, next week, five years
from now.
Who is sincere?
Who really is questioning? who is really
hungry for these things and doesn't and
feels like something doesn't sit right
in Adventism.
This is the lynchpin doctrine of this
movement, folks.
It's the lynch pin. I know that the
great controversy theme is how
everything's funneled through and the
investigative judgment is what they're
well the shut door and then the
investigative judgment is essentially
what their roots essentially go back to.
But in terms of you talk to an
Adventist, this is the one. And I'm
telling you, if you can come to
understand the beauty of the new
creation, I mean, you're if you come to
understand that, man, you're going to
have to abandon Adventism. Not just on
the the fronts of the Sabbath, but all
the other implications that it has.
Their whole system is an esqueological
system that is built upon a certain
order and chain of events all having to
be true. If any of that's thrown off, if
the new creation's here, bonk, the whole
chain breaks. It doesn't matter how
consistent that chain of things is. If
something is simply off or out of order,
the whole chain is scrapped. And that's
the case. This argument absolutely
buries the SDA teaching on this.
So, I hope tonight was beneficial for uh
Adventists, former Adventists, never
been an Adventist, not a Christian,
whoever. Um that's the historic
understanding of why the church meets on
Sunday. You may have heard people say,
"Oh, because of the resurrection." Well,
that's a summary statement
that is
packing with it so much information
that's not being stated. That's why
people are saying that they've probably
heard this from somebody before, but
they haven't done a real theological dig
on this. There needs to be more theology
in the Christian church around this
topic. And stop conceding this to groups
like Seventh Day Adventist where their
silly arguments don't work on this at
all. And again, they they're they can't
deal with the grammar. Sorry, but you're
not going to be able to deal with it's
not going to change. It doesn't change.
And the facts are
Hebrews 4 specifically tying all this
together, but just the biblical theology
of the whole Bible, the the narrative
around what the Sabbath was about
buries this idea. They're always wanting
to go back, back to Sinai, back to Eden,
back to the old creation Sabbath, back
to the old covenant. It's always back,
back, back, man. Christians aren't doing
that. Like, we're not always looking
back. Go back, back, back. Bring them to
the foot of Sinai so they can hear the
fear and terror of the Lord like Ellen
White said did preachers. It's like it's
just always going backwards. If you're
an Adventist and you're sick of going
backwards, come join us. We're looking
forward. That's what Sunday is about.
It's about looking forward. It's seeing
that the that the Sabbath is going
somewhere. It's about more than just a
day. This idea of like, oh, Isaiah 66
says we're going to keep the Sabbath in
heaven. Yeah, it says the new moons,
too. It's not You're missing what's
being said there as well. It's not going
to be days like that. Eternity itself is
going to be the eternal rest that
remains. And you get there by being in
Christ by faith.
So, enter into Christ by faith today.
Stop trusting in anything that you're
doing. Being a vegetarian, going to
church on Saturday, whatever it may be.
That's not the seal of God. The seal of
God is the Holy Spirit that's given to
people who are in Christ. He's the seal
and the guarantee of the promises, the
eternal rest, our bodies being
glorified, resurrection, all of that
stuff. The spirit is a down payment.
Ephesians 4:30, 1 Corinthians, uh, 2
Corinthians 1:21-22,
and 2 Corinthians 5:5.
He is the guarantee of our inheritance,
the promises. So believe that today,
friend. Believe that today.
Next week, we're going to be doing a Q&A
session on the channel for those who are
curious. You can show up. You can bring
questions about the Sabbath, whatever it
may be. Um, not any questions, I guess.
It's going to be theologically based.
It's not going to be personal questions
and stuff like that, but um got to do
another Q&A session next Thursday. So,
if you're an Adventist, show up. Don't
go around telling people, "Oh, he he
won't talk with
don't go around. You're going to dig
yourself in a hole because there's
eventually going to be a paper trail of
all these Q&As's that I'm going to be
doing." So, don't don't say that. Either
show up or, you know, don't don't go
around saying that because I'm not
scared of your guys' theology. I'm not
scared of going to the Bible. I'm not
scared of any of this. So, Q&A session
next Thursday. Um the only live stream
next week and then uh the week after
that. I can't remember exactly, but we
have a couple more guests that are
queued up. Um dates haven't necessarily
been finalized on those things, but um
we will see how um those things pan out.
If you like content like this, please be
so kind as to smash that like button,
subscribe, and ring that notification
bell. And if you want more resources,
you want to partner with us, uh, learn
more about what we're doing, go to
answeringadventism.com.
answering adventism.com. As always,
folks, until next time, God bless.
[Music]